Hallo Leute.
Suskei Akriege.
So.
Was habe ich die Woche verpasst?
Gab es irgendwas Spannendes?
Wo wir noch nicht drüber gesprochen haben.
Sisko Sicherheitslücke.
Haben wir uns schon drüber ausgelassen.
Und so irgendwas Spannendes, was ich übersehen habe.
Ihr seid ja noch immer voll im Bilde, Chatge.
IIQ.
Ihr wisst doch Bescheid.
Ich wurde übrigens gestern auf dem Fahrrad vom Auto umgefahren.
Falls jemand noch nicht mitgekriegt hat.
Ich habe es ja gestern auf Twitter gepostet.
Ich erzähle auch gleich noch was dazu.
Auf dem Fahrradweg.
Bäm.
Richtig MonkaS.
Man könnte.
Wo habe ich das?
Man könnte fast schon sagen MonkaStier.
Ich erzähle gleich noch was.
Ich erzähle gleich noch was dazu.
Ich zeige euch auch mal ein Bild von.
Von Google Maps.
Von der Stelle.
Das hat jetzt nichts damit zu tun.
Wollen wir hier was trinken.
Ja, so weit geht es.
Also wie gesagt.
Ich habe ein bisschen.
Ja, ein bisschen am Arm.
Am Bein.
So ein bisschen abgeschürft.
Und mir tut es an der Hüfte weh.
Da wo ich drauf gefallen bin.
Das war es echt.
Also es ist glaube ich.
Klimpflicher ausgegangen.
Als es hätte.
Also als.
Als es anders hätte.
Sagen wir mal so.
Hätte anders laufen können.
Ja.
Was ist passiert?
Ich erzähle gleich ein bisschen was zu.
Wenn ich.
Wenn ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind.
Weil ich muss es wahrscheinlich noch fünfmal erzählen.
Heute könntest du jetzt Server Meister.
Mal das Star Citizen Server Mashing anschauen.
Mir verraten, ob es tatsächlich so besonders ist.
Auch wenn du nicht ausgeben.
Also wenn du mir irgendwie einen ordentlichen Link zu dem Artikel.
Oder so gibst.
Server Mashing klingt jetzt ehrlich gesagt.
Nach einer ähnlichen Sache.
Wie das MMOs schon seit Jahren machen.
Dass das eben alles relativ.
Flüssige, flüssige Transitions für den Spieler.
Zwischen unterschiedlichen Servern.
Wo unterschiedliche Zonen drauf laufen.
Oder eventuell die gleiche Zone mehrfach läuft.
Je nachdem wie voll sie ist.
Und sowas.
Klingt jetzt.
Ja mir tut es immer noch.
Das Bein ein bisschen weh.
Also die Hüfte ehrlich gesagt.
Am Arm habe ich mir jetzt so ein Verband rum gemacht.
Weil natürlich.
Das genau an der Stelle ist.
Wo ich den Arm.
Auf den.
Auf die hier Unterlage.
Lege und.
Sackt halt ein bisschen.
Ja wie gesagt.
Ich sag gleich was zu.
Kommst du weiß ich nicht.
Ich such mir wahrscheinlich einen Anwalt am.
Ach Entschädigung ist Blödsinn.
Ich will einfach nur das Fahrrad repariert wird.
Und bezahlt wird.
Oder keine Ahnung.
Ich hab mir jetzt dazu überlegt.
Ich such mir einen Anwalt am Montag.
Der das oder jetzt.
Und gebe das denen.
Die sollen das machen.
Ich hab da keine Ahnung von.
Ich will mich damit auch nicht groß auseinandersetzen.
Sollen die das machen.
Und aus meiner Sicht ist das ganze eh relativ.
Naja klar.
Ich zeig es euch gleich.
Ich zeig es euch gleich auf Google Maps.
Und dann werde ich nichts sagen.
Weil man weiß ja nie was da vor und gegen einen.
Für einen oder gegen einen verwendet werden kann.
Aber ich kann euch die Stelle zeigen.
Also aus meiner Sicht ist es relativ klar.
Mit dem ich.
Auf dem Fahrradweg umgefahren wurde.
Gibt es da glaube ich nicht allzu viel.
Ja auf jeden Fall.
Aber die Sache ist halt die.
Ich will mein Fahrrad möglichst schnell wieder.
Wieder fit haben.
Ich ruf morgen einen Anwalt an.
Frag den wie man das macht.
Weil am liebsten würde ich morgen einfach das Fahrrad.
Zur Werkstatt bringen.
Und sagen hier guck mal.
Rad eiert.
Macht mal please entweder ausbeugen.
Oder macht mal am besten.
Weil ich muss ja nicht selbst bezahlen.
Gleich wenn ihr das für sinnvoll haltet.
Ein neues Rad rein.
Neuen Reifen vielleicht auch gleich drauf.
Ich weiß nicht ob der noch einen Schlag hat.
Macht ein neues Rad rein.
Und das einzige wo ich mir halt ein bisschen Gedanken mache ist.
Also für mich sieht es so aus.
Als ist das vordere Rad ein bisschen verbogen.
Scheibenbremse.
Scheibenbremse selbst weiß ich nicht.
Glaub ich nicht.
Und das Rad ausgetauscht werden.
Das Lenkerband.
Ist an der einen Seite aufgerissen.
Das muss man wahrscheinlich neu wickeln.
Das kostet auch nicht die Welt.
Und der Rahmen.
Das ist halt ein Carbon Rahmen.
Der hat ein paar Kratzer.
Und das ist halt so ein Ding.
Bei Carbon weißt du halt nie.
Ob der nur ein paar Kratzer hat.
Bei Carbon verzieht sich ja meistens nichts.
Sondern es bricht halt.
Und deswegen ist halt die Sache.
Man weiß halt nicht.
Das sollen die sich in der Werkstatt angucken.
Nicht das der Rahmen wirklich irgendwelche Risse hat.
Und mir das Fahrrad auseinander bricht.
Oder so dann demnächst.
Ich kann das nicht einschätzen.
Ich glaube das ja nicht.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Ich meine ich bin damit noch.
Heimgefahren danach.
Naja.
Der Restwert ist relativ easy.
Das Fahrrad ist erst einen Monat alt.
Aber wir müssen hier keine Rechtsberatung im Twitch Chat machen.
Deswegen suche ich mir einen Anwalt.
Der Verkehrsstells macht.
Und dann.
Und dann sollen die das machen.
Das passt schon so ungefähr.
Ja.
Das will ich nicht.
Oh das ist mir aber zu high IQ für heute Morgen.
Ich mach mir das mal auf.
Ich lass gar nichts machen.
Ich suche mir morgen früh einen Anwalt.
Der sich mit sowas auskennt.
Und der soll das machen.
Ich mach gar nichts selbst.
Ich hab.
Man muss wissen wann man keine Ahnung hat.
Und das Leute machen lassen.
Die hoffentlich Ahnung haben.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ah jetzt irgendwie läuft meine Nase übelst auf einmal.
Lass doch mal kurz gucken.
Hanau.
Verkehrsrecht. Anwalt.
Was gibt es denn da so für Leute.
Gucken.
Wer hat denn gute Bewertung.
Ach was sucht man da überhaupt.
Verkehrsrecht. Unfall.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Aber was sucht man da am besten.
Top ADAC Anwalt.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wenn man das in den Namen schreibt.
Klingt das irgendwie schon mal nicht so geil.
Hanau hat auch nur 4 Komma.
Was ist mit Google Maps los.
Alter es ist ja voll.
Es ist ja voll.
Guck mal das ist gar nicht so weit weg von mir.
3 Komma 9 da gehe ich nicht hin.
Guck mal wir haben 4 Komma.
4 Komma 4.
Hat keine Web.
Doch hat eine Website.
Okay zeig mal her.
Anwalt für Verkehrsrecht in Hanau.
Ansprechpartner bei Verkehrsunfällen.
Hatten sie einen Unfall.
Anwalt Verkehrsrecht Hanau.
Klingt ja schon.
Keine Ahnung wo ich da hingehe.
Lass mal kurz hat er Bewertung.
Was hat er für Bewertung.
Reviews.
Superkanzler sehr freundlich kompetent.
Das ist ja alles 3 Jahre her.
Furchtbar vor 5 Jahren.
Da würde ich jetzt nicht mal allzu viel drauf geben.
Der Rest war eigentlich ausnahmslos positiv.
Ja keine Ahnung.
Ich muss mal gucken wo ich hingehe.
Ich suche mir.
Das schöne ist.
Also erste Beratung ist ja meistens kostenlos.
Und nachdem.
Das aus meiner Sicht eh relativ klar ist.
Dass ich da absolut gar nichts für kann.
Ne ne ne.
Ich gehe da gar nicht hin.
Ich weiß noch nicht.
Guckt mal hier.
Gibt ja jede Menge.
Ich muss die hier erstmal durchgucken.
Wer da gute Bewertungen hat.
Wer sich mit Verkehrs- und Unfallstells auskennt.
Und dann.
Und dann suche ich mal.
Irgendwas raus.
Arbeitsrecht.
Arbeitsrecht, Zivilrecht und was sonst noch.
Auch Verkehr.
Unsere Leistung.
Unfallregulierung.
Ja das klingt doch auch nicht schlecht.
KISIM.
Ja irgendeinen suche ich mir mal raus in Hanau.
Ich gehe davon aus.
Dass das so ein einfacher Fall ist.
Das kann wahrscheinlich jeder.
Nein die Polizei war nicht da.
Und meine GoPro lief auch nicht.
Aber ich habe mit meinem Handy Zeug aufgenommen.
Und als ich daheim war.
Habe ich Bilder gemacht.
Ja klar was soll ich machen.
Ich habe Bilder gemacht von.
Von der Straße.
Von dem Fahrradweg.
Von dem Auto.
Inklusive Nummernschild.
Und als ich daheim war.
Habe ich noch ein paar Bilder.
Noch ein paar mehr Bilder.
Von meinem Fahrrad gemacht.
Und von meinem Arm.
Und meinem Bein.
Der Rest.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube den Rest lasse ich das echt.
Den Anwand regeln.
Weil ganz ehrlich.
Dann sollen die sich mit der Versicherung auseinandersetzen.
Dann sollen die auch sagen was ich mache.
Also mein Wunsch wäre halt.
Dass mein Fahrrad möglichst schnell wieder fit gemacht wird.
Dass ich das benutzen kann.
Nein nein.
Danach.
Anzeige macht null.
Anzeige ist raus.
Was passiert ist.
Ich hatte gestern jemand auf dem Fahrradweg umgefahren mit dem Auto.
Den man auch hier meint.
Max FPS.
Ich habe doch gestern noch ein Bild vom Arm gepostet.
Ich habe euch mal.
Ich habe euch.
Ne 100 pro GoPro kannst du gar nicht machen.
Wenn ich 3 Stunden fahre.
Ich mache gar nichts.
Ich werde mir am Montag einen Anwalt suchen.
Der sich damit auskennt.
Der soll mir sagen was ich machen soll.
Wir brauchen keine Twitch Place Verkehrsrecht.
Und Twitch berät mich.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Ich suche mir einen Anwalt der sich damit auskennt.
Der soll das machen.
Da habe ich ja gepostet.
Ich habe mal darauf verzichtet.
Mein Hintern zu leaken.
Auf Twitch.
Nur Arm leak.
Und es sieht am Pobbes.
Sieht es genauso aus.
Nur größer.
Also am Pobbes ist halt so der komplette.
Komplette Pobbes Übergang zum Oberschenkel.
Ja.
Ich wurde umgefahren.
Ich bin gestern.
Mitten auf dem Fahrradweg.
Ich kann euch auch gleich.
Ich zeige euch auch gleich auf Google.
Google Street View.
Wobei sollte ich das.
Ist das taktisch geschickt wenn ich es auf Google Street View zeige.
Keine Ahnung ob man da irgendwas.
Irgendwas leakt.
Was ich nicht leaken sollte.
Na gut warum eigentlich nicht.
Warum eigentlich nicht.
Ich meine.
Der Ort ist ja relativ unstrittig.
Beistang für den Sub.
Wie weit ist das weg.
Das ist nicht direkt bei mir in der Nähe.
Das ist schon ein bisschen weiter weg.
Ne ne ne ne.
Ich zeige es euch gleich.
Ich warte aber noch bis der Stream so richtig angelaufen ist.
Sonst muss ich das E5 mal erzählen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wie sieht das Rad aus.
Ja leider nicht ganz so nice.
Das vordere Rad ist verbogen.
Zumindest das was ich jetzt auf den ersten Blick gesehen habe.
Und.
Das Band am Lenker ist gerissen.
Und der Rahmen hat Kratzer.
Nachdem es ein Carbonrahmen ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Klar hatte ich den Helm auf.
Zum Glück.
Aber auf dem Kopf habe ich nichts groß abgekriegt.
Weil meine Brille und so war auch noch aufgesteckt.
Auf dem Helm danach.
Und so überhaupt kein Ding.
Und der Helm hat auch nichts abgekriegt.
Hat dich der Typ erkannt.
Nein.
Aber ich meine.
Ein random Dude auf dem Fahrradweg.
Da denkt man nicht.
Das ist bestimmt Wubblors.
Das ist bestimmt der Max von Youtube.
Den kenne ich.
Wo auch immer.
Der hat mich nicht erkannt.
Ne ne.
Ist nichts gewesen.
Chat.
Entspannt euch.
Ich gehe am Montag zum Anwalt.
Er soll mir sagen was ich machen soll.
Ich kann da auch nicht auf Schadensersatz verklagen.
Oder sowas.
An meiner Person.
Keine Ahnung.
Soll man Fahrrad wieder.
Soll man Fahrrad bezahlen.
Also die Reparatur bezahlen.
Ja.
Mich hat jemand umgefahren auf dem Fahrradweg.
Das ist passiert gestern.
Guck hier.
Ich habe nur den A-Mark geleakt.
Den Rest nicht.
Den Rest gibt es.
Ja.
Ich bin weiter rechts geschwenkt.
Aber nicht Onlyfans.
Wenn schon Fansly.
Alter.
Oder wie heißt das andere?
Gibt es auch noch so ein drittes.
Was sich etabliert hat.
Vor einer Weile.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern.
Vor 1-2 Jahren.
Hat Onlyfans doch gesagt.
Sie wollen weg von diesem Schmuddel Image.
Und hin zu seriösem Content.
Wie beispielsweise Fitness.
Und sowas.
Ich habe noch nie wieder was von gehört.
Oder?
Ich glaube die haben festgestellt.
Dass sie einfach viel zu viel Geld.
Mit Onlyfans.
Ab 18 machen.
Die hätten ja komplett.
Ihr gesamtes Geschäftsmodell irgendwie gekillt.
Hätten die jetzt nur noch seriös gemacht.
Weiß gar nicht.
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung.
Wie die damals auf diese glorreiche Idee gekommen sind.
Ist ein bisschen wie vor ein paar Jahren.
Vor ein paar Jahren.
Haben sie ja auch auf Pornhub.
Aufgeräumt.
Da haben sie ja sogar den Account von Tanzverbot damals gelöscht.
Leute ihr wollt nicht wissen.
Was der hatte auf.
Der hatte einen Pornhub Account.
Wobei so schlimm war das gar nicht.
Ich habe da mal rein.
Zu Studienzwecken reingeguckt.
Bei Tanzverbot.
Auf Pornhub.
Eigentlich war da nichts der Rede wert.
Aber der Account wurde auch gelöscht.
Genau.
Wir programmieren den eigenen Fanschamp.
Ja es gibt so ein paar Sachen.
Die will man eigentlich gar nicht wissen.
Unbedingt.
Das habe ich mir dann auch gedacht.
Eigentlich hätte ich das gar nicht so genau wissen wollen.
Ja.
Die sind weg von mir.
Die sind ja auch echt bescheuert gewesen damit.
Es gab ja im Endeffekt.
Damals nur Tumblr.
So was das angeht.
Ab 18 Content.
Und dann haben sie irgendwann gesagt.
Wir schmeißen die Leute jetzt raus.
Und niemand interessiert sich mehr für Tumblr.
Ja genau stimmt.
Ich erinnere mich.
Das war wegen Abrechnung und sowas.
Was aber allen auch bescheuert ist.
Weil du kannst mit Kreditkarte nach wie vor auch bezahlen.
Auf Onlyfans.
Ne.
Und was da gibt.
Ist ja im Prinzip genau das gleiche.
Macht eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied.
Die Logik muss man nicht immer ganz nachvollziehen.
Waren da nicht irgendwelche Reactions.
Ey.
Leute.
Ich will mich da gar nicht so genau mehr dran erinnern.
Ich habe da einfach nur mal JustForFun nachgeguckt.
Es war nichts wildes.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern.
Auf Tanz4Bowls Pornhub Account.
Gab es im Endeffekt Videos.
Wo er.
Nur mit einem Handtuch bekleidet.
Vor der Kamera saß.
Und erzählt hat.
Was er sich jetzt für Porns anguckt.
Total unspektakulär.
Nichts wildes.
Also wenn man so will.
Das der Account weg ist.
Ist nicht weiter wild.
Aber ich fand es halt nur lustig.
Das Pornhub damals den Account gelöscht hat.
Für im Endeffekt nichts.
Aber ja das war wahrscheinlich auch im Zuge dieser Kreditkarten.
Sache.
Es war echt.
Was ihn da geritten hat.
Sich einen Account zu machen.
Aber jeder wo er Bock drauf hat.
Ja.
Ich glaube nicht das man damit was verdient hat.
Echt.
Weird Champ.
PSVolks danke für den Sub.
Und wer denn noch.
Habe ich beißt.
Falls ich dich nicht erwähnt habe.
Und ich muss mal kurz in meine Übersicht gucken.
Gestern.
Gestern Abend.
Habe ich mich nochmal remote auf die Arbeit eingeloggt.
5 Minuten habe ich auch nicht abgerechnet.
So einfach kann es gehen.
Wenn der Arbeitgeber sich normal verhält.
Da guckt man auch mal 10 oder 15 Minuten.
Just for fun abends nochmal nach.
Und.
Ich wollte nachgucken.
Ob.
Das Blockchain Download Zeug.
Funktioniert hat.
Ich wollte mir Polygon.
Polygon Snapshots runterladen.
Und.
Also Polygon.
Blockchain Snapshots runterladen.
Und das dauert immer eine ganze Weile.
Weil das sind fast 3 Terabyte.
Und die werden dann noch entpackt.
Und da wollte ich nachgucken.
Wie weit die Kiste ist.
Und ich habe gesehen.
Das der bei 55% abgebrochen ist beim entpacken.
Weil Checksum Error.
Also Download nochmal neu gestartet.
Gestern Abend habe ich auch gedacht.
Fuck man.
Warum ist das Zeug immer so Schrott alles.
Also eins habe ich jetzt echt gemerkt.
In meiner neuen Stelle.
Mit Cloud Infrastruktur.
Und auch recht viel unterschiedliche Blockchain.
Ja ne Infrastruktur.
Technologien.
Das ist alles unfertiger Schrott.
Das ist alles echt Alpha Beta Software.
Da funktioniert nichts.
Und wenn du dann bei denen.
Also die haben ja alle immer keine.
Supportmöglichkeiten logischerweise.
Das ist ja.
Meistens nichts super offizielles.
Wo es dann irgendwie eine Ansprechstelle gibt.
Die haben meistens Discord.
Discord Channel.
Die ganzen Blockchain Dudes.
Und da ist immer die Hölle drin los.
Da kriegst du auch keinen Support für irgendwas.
Also kannst du komplett knicken.
Es ist komplett pipega alles.
Gestern Google Chrome Update bekommen.
Sieht jetzt komisch aus.
Echt ich habe noch kein Chrome Update.
Wir können ja mal gucken.
Chrome Update.
Was es da neues gibt.
Fünf starke Verbesserung für die Adresszeile.
Okay.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Chatgear.
Wie macht man einen.
Wie macht man einen manuellen.
Chrome Update Check.
Weiß das jemand.
Findest du die Idee hinter Blockchain gut.
Bei Blockchain geht es ja nicht.
Prinzipiell immer um Geld.
Also der Ansatz.
Ja.
Man könnte ja sogar so weit gehen argumentieren.
Das Git eines der ersten Blockchains war.
Natürlich.
Nicht ganz streng genommen.
Es ist ja ohne Probleme rewriten und manipulieren.
Manipulieren nicht.
Aber rewriten.
Aber es hat gewisse Züge davon.
Was Hilfe über Chromium.
Ist aktuell.
Mir sieht es immer noch genauso aus.
Alles fit.
Naja.
Eigentlich nicht.
Ich hatte gestern auf dem Fahrradweg jemand umgefahren.
Aber ich wollte euch das ja zeigen.
Auf Google Maps.
Es kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an was die da machen.
Ja.
Im Prinzip ist es das meistens.
Weil immer irgendwas.
Geproved.
Und gestaked.
Und was auch immer gemacht werden muss.
Also insofern.
Ich bin da im Detail auch nicht so richtig drin.
Wie das jetzt im Detail.
Bei den unterschiedlichen Implementierungen.
Funktioniert.
Aber in der Regel läuft es schon.
Irgendwo immer ein bisschen auf.
Ich will jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen.
Energieverschwendung drauf.
Aber man muss auf jeden Fall.
Einiges an Energie reinstecken.
Wie hieß diese Blockchain nochmal.
Mit Storage.
Wo sogar der Auer.
Mal mitgemacht hat.
Weiß das noch jemand.
Diese Storage.
Storage Blockchain.
Chia.
Chia genau.
Wollte ich mal gucken.
Wie hat sich denn der Kurs so.
Ey guck mal.
Über.
Das war die Zeit.
Wo das hier ein bisschen angesagt war.
Es ist halt einfach mal.
Komplett abgeschissen.
Alter.
Guckt mal hier.
1300.
Bam 20.
Not stonks.
Ja.
Reverse stonks.
Du.
Ja mein Arm.
By the way.
Monitor auf den Kopf stellen.
Ja dann geht es hoch.
Dann ist es zwar immer noch grün und rot.
So falsch.
Okay.
Damit wir das jetzt aus dem Weg haben.
Ich zeige euch mal.
Wo ich gestern umgefahren wurde.
Maps.
Google.
Ich bin hier lang gefahren.
Und hier raus wurde ich umgefahren.
Wie gesagt.
Zum genauen Unfall Hergang.
Will ich mich nicht äußern.
Wer weiß was da für oder gegen einen verwendet werden kann.
Aber.
Ich finde für mich ist es relativ offensichtlich.
Wenn du hier raus fährst.
Hast du das Schild.
Das ist ein Fahrradweg.
Und du hast das Vorfahrt 8 Schild.
Also insofern.
Gestern.
Nicht in your face.
Aber in your Fahrrad.
So sah es da aus.
Also insofern.
Hat es mich da ganz schön umgehauen.
Kann man.
Naja.
Es hat schon eine Kurve.
Das Fahrrad.
Ne.
Das Vorderrad nicht mehr.
Der Rest ist glaube ich recht easy zu fixen.
Aber das Vorderrad ist im Arsch.
Also ich kann Finger bewegen.
Arm bewegen.
Also was ich jetzt habe.
Ich habe ein bisschen abgeschürft am Arm.
Am Oberschenkel.
Zum Popper Center.
Dann habe ich.
An der Hüfte tut es mir noch ein bisschen weh.
Wahrscheinlich kriegst du da einen blauen Fleck.
Und.
Tja.
Ich merke es auf der anderen Seite.
Im Arm ein bisschen hier oben.
Am Muskel.
Bin ich da drauf.
Hab ich mich da abgestürzt.
Und ansonsten.
Links und rechts.
Ein bisschen im Schienbein und in der Wade.
Wahrscheinlich weil ich hinten.
Im Prinzip.
Sind die mir von der Seite rein gefahren.
Ich bin auf der Motorhaube gelandet.
Und dann bin ich runter gefallen.
Und.
Das ist.
Also keine Ahnung ob es die Speichen sind.
Ich denke es ist das Rad.
Weil das Rad eiert halt auch komplett.
Also ja.
Vielleicht sind es die Speichen.
Deswegen wird es ja auch schräg.
Also ehrlich gesagt.
Um mich selbst.
Mache ich mir jetzt in dem Fall gar nicht so viel Sorgen.
Ich denke mal in 2-3 Tagen ist das alles wieder gut.
Hoffe ich mal.
Je nachdem was der Anwalt sagt.
Gehe ich vielleicht doch nochmal zum Doktor.
Und lasse das fotografieren.
Oder aufnehmen oder was auch immer.
Aber.
Mir persönlich wäre es tatsächlich wichtiger.
Wenn das so gefixt wird.
Erstens weil nächste Woche.
Vielleicht noch 1-2 Tage.
Mal ganz gutes.
Jetzt kommt der Chat wieder hier.
Schmerzensgelb.
Psychischer Schaden.
Wer weiß.
Muss man alles mal untersuchen lassen.
Aber zumindest körperlich.
Muss ich sagen.
Ich glaube nicht dass das irgendwie was bleibendes ist.
Man weiß es natürlich nicht.
Gerade an der Hüfte.
Das kann ich mir jetzt so aktuell nicht vorstellen.
Zumindest.
Haben die eine ganz schöne Delle.
In der Motorhaube.
Nein war ich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt.
Zu genaueren Sachen.
Mehr Details erzähle ich nicht.
Ganz schöne Beule in der Motorhaube.
Und das erste.
Fand ich auch eine geile Aussage.
Das erste ist.
Was der Fahrer gesagt hat.
Ist.
Er guckt eigentlich.
Nach rechts.
Weil die meisten Fahrradfahrer von rechts kommen.
War halt kacke.
Ich kam halt von links.
Aber halt auf dem Fahrradweg.
Jaja Chat.
Ich gehe am Montag zum Anwalt.
Und dann lasse ich mir von dem sagen.
Vor allem.
Das ist halt falsch.
Man fährt auch auf dem Fahrradweg rechte Seite.
Das ist ein Fahrradweg.
Da kann man in beide Richtungen drauf fahren.
Sieht man sogar auf dem Schild.
Dass Fahrräder von beiden Richtungen kommen.
Ähm.
Ja das habe ich gemerkt.
Das habe ich gemerkt.
Der Aufprall war weicher als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Aber trotzdem hat es ein bisschen.
Ging es ein bisschen auf die Hüfte.
Wie gesagt Max.
Guck hier ist das Bild.
Hier ist das Bild.
Vorfahrt achten.
Fahrradweg von links und rechts.
Übrigens gegen dieses Schild hier oben.
Ist anscheinend auch schon mal einer dagegen gefahren.
Oder sie haben es zu fest getackert.
Also ich finde.
Aus meiner Sicht ist die.
Aus meiner Sicht ist die Lage relativ klar.
Also.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht.
Ich habe ja auch noch gebremst.
Bam.
So sieht es aus.
In your face.
Der Fahrer war auf jeden Fall sehr fertig mit den Nerven.
Ich muss übelst rum geflucht haben.
Als ich auf dem Boden lag.
Ich weiß nicht mehr was ich gesagt habe.
Aber ich glaube ich habe die.
Ich habe die da irgendwie.
Ziemlich beleidigt so.
Ich weiß nicht.
Oder auch nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mich ziemlich aufgeregt.
Wobei ich glaube ich.
Ich glaube ich habe die gar nicht großartig beleidigt.
Ich glaube ich habe nur irgendwas rumgeschrieben.
Was soll die Scheiße hier ist Fahrradweg.
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Ich kann mich nicht so richtig daran erinnern.
Ich glaube ich habe gesagt.
Fahrradweg.
Keck Wait.
Was soll die Scheiße hier ist Fahrradweg.
So wie ich mich kenne.
Habe ich wahrscheinlich auch ein Twitch Emote.
Hinten dran gehängt.
Monkastir Alter habe ich bestimmt gesagt.
Monkastir.
Wurde die Polizei hinzugezogen.
Fotos gemacht.
Vom Fahrradweg.
Vom Auto.
Ähm.
Kontaktdaten.
Aufgeschrieben.
Autofotografiert mit Nummernschild.
Ja wie gesagt.
Aus meiner Sicht ist es auch sehr eindeutig.
Wer es da verkackt hat.
Ich meine du hast als Autofahrer ja eigentlich prinzipiell immer gelitten.
Egal was ist.
Wenn du einen Fahrradfahrer umfährst.
Aber in dem Fall ist glaube ich echt.
Ziemlich eindeutig.
Was ich witzig fand.
Guckt mal hier auf Twitter.
Die meisten Leute haben ja geschrieben.
Ey alles gut und so.
Und dann kamen schon manche.
Manche kamen wieder an so.
Ich kenne die ganzen scheiß Fahrradfahrer.
Ihr seid selber schuld.
Und sowas.
Irgendwo.
Sorry.
Aber das glaube ich tatsächlich.
Ich weiß wie Fahrradfahrer drauf sind.
Okay.
Also der hatte schon mal Probleme mit Fahrradfahrern.
Das heißt prinzipiell pauschal.
Ist jetzt bei allen.
Das ist alles immer Fake.
Was ist denn das eigentlich für einer.
Lass mal kurz auf sein Profil gucken.
Wobei ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Auf random Profile zu gehen.
Ist eigentlich echt immer problematisch.
Oh.
Das ist.
Oh Gott da will ich gar nicht weiter scrollen.
Wer weiß was da jetzt alles kommt.
Ich lass mal lieber bleiben.
Ja Bro.
Der Name allein schon.
Ich scroll mal lieber nicht weiter.
Wer weiß was da jetzt gleich noch alles kommt.
Wahrscheinlich ist das der eigentliche Fake.
Der Account.
Den er nur gemacht hat um quasi so diese.
Diese eine Sache überall drunter zu pasten.
Ich habe ein Paypal Spenden Konto.
Aber ich will keine spenden.
Entweder Prime Sub.
Oder du kannst auch auf Youtube subscriben.
Oder du kannst einfach so zugucken.
Mach einfach Prime Sub.
Wenn du welche hast.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich bin da auch nicht wirklich drauf angewiesen.
Ich finde es natürlich nice.
Was nebenbei verdienen kann.
Aber mir ist lieber die Leute kommen ins Stream.
Und freuen sich das das Stream ist.
Auch wenn ich manchmal natürlich ein bisschen sellout mache.
Also wer noch Prime Sub übrig hat.
Ich habe da natürlich nichts dagegen.
Aber ist schön das ihr am Start seid.
Das reicht mir ja alles schon.
Ich habe den Eindruck.
Leute das.
Es gefährlich ist dort zu arbeiten.
Wo ich jetzt arbeite.
Weil mein Chef.
Hat mir letztens erzählt.
Der hatte auch einen Autounfall.
Aber er im Auto.
Versus Auto.
Nicht wie ich.
Fahrrad versus Auto.
Also anscheinend scheint der Arbeitgeber ein erhöhtes Risiko zu haben.
Das Leute die dort im Linux Team arbeiten.
Unfälle abbekommen.
Ich hatte mein Leben lang noch keinen richtigen Unfall.
Also Unfall schon.
Aber noch keinen Verkehrsunfall.
Und ich hatte diesmal auch übelst Glück.
Es ist ja nichts großartiges zumindest an mir.
So wie es jetzt aussieht.
Passiert.
Dann wird es erstmal losgehen.
Stimmt vielleicht liegt das doch daran.
Die wollen testen ob ihre Workflows funktionieren.
Vielleicht hat hier jemand zufällig eine Ahnung.
Ich kriege beim Öffnen von CUDAmang folgende Message.
OpenMEM FAILED
Ich habe keine Anhaltspunkte.
Ich würde sagen.
Die Anwendung ist kacke programmiert.
Das liegt nicht an deinem Rechner.
Die Anwendung ist scheiße.
Die macht Zeug was nicht funktioniert.
Äh macht Zeug was nicht funktioniert.
OpenMEM FAILED
dass er versucht das zu starten mit gpu acceleration und das nicht funktioniert
wegen einem grafikkarten treiber und so cute ist da bis gut versucht beim
starten rauszufinden was der was das beste render backend ist für deine
anwendung du kannst mit kommandozeilen parameter forcen dass das die cute
anwendung in software rendering gestartet wird irgendwie fragt mich
nicht mehr aus dem kopf wie das funktioniert und vielleicht geht es mit
software rendering weil cute hat unterschiedlichsten möglichkeiten gut
kann rendern per ich glaube valken mittlerweile per opengl per direct 3d
per oder direct 2d ist es in dem weise 3d also da wird x es kann rendern per
per ich habe vergessen wie das heißt per
opengl zu direct x translation layer und es kann software ändern muss mal gucken
und muss mal gucken
ob du software rendering einschalten kannst dann ist die anwendung vielleicht
was animation angeht ein bisschen ein bisschen ruckelig aber das ist nicht so
schlimm da kannst du gucken ob sie zumindest öffnet ich glaube nicht dass
es an deinem rechner irgendwie liegt dass die dass ich in cute anwendung nicht
starten lässt es liegt an der anwendung was können wir uns den acht chat ganz
wichtig wir müssen uns ja weekly angucken was ist rendering wie die bildinformationen auf
deinen bildschirm kommen also klassischerweise ganz früher war rendering ungefähr so das nehme
ich jetzt mal als beispiel weil das also rendering würde ich bin ich kenne die genaue definition ich
also ich würde sagen zu rendering gehört der weg wie halt die grafik informationen sowohl
aufbereitet werden in ein darstellbares format für deinen für deine grafikkarte und letztendlich
die grafikkarte die das ganze dann auf dem bildschirm anzeigt also du hast vielleicht
in deinem spiel irgendwelche 3d objekte das muss ja alles berechnet werden letztendlich in
den bild sagen wir 920 mal 1080 in rgb so also quasi irgendwelche 3d abstrakte 3d kulisse muss
umgewandelt werden in ein flaches pixelbild so und das ist das was ich als das was ich als
rendern bezeichnen würde also was quasi einen internen anwendungs state der umgewandelt werden
muss in ein pixelbild und dann und das so wie das so lief das früher und dann wurde das quasi
per dos zeiten und windows 3 1 zeiten lief das noch so und dann wurde das quasi direkt in den
grafikkarten speicher kopiert und die grafikkarte hat es dann auf dem beim nächsten refresh auf dem
bildschirm angezeigt so das würde ich sagen das ist rendern oder
so mal aus dem ärmel geschüttelt irgendwas so und irgendwann haben sie festgestellt das ist
keine allzu gute idee direkt aus dem grafikspeicher aufs display zu rendern und daraufhin hat man dann
sowas gemacht wie double buffer man hat man hat ein speicher gehabt wo das bild rein gerendert
wird und ein speicher gehabt für das bild was auf monitor angezeigt wird und man hat immer in den
grafikkarten speicher geändert also der dann nicht angezeigt wird und dann hat man den backbuffer wenn er
fertig war rüber kopiert in den speicher was auf bild angezeigt wird hat dazu geführt dass es halt
viel weniger flimmert und das hat das alles insgesamt halt weniger weniger hakelig aussieht
das war so eines der ersten sachen die sie sich ausgedacht haben mittlerweile ist ja mit direktem
grafikkarten ram access ehemaliger grafikkarten und die grafikkarten haben sich dann auch wieder
eingestellt das heißt heute musst du durch sowas wie opengl und irx gehen oder valken oder sonst
was irgendwas was sein grafikkarten treiber kann ja das ist das ist was komplett anderes das würde
ich das würde ich serverseitiges rendering hat nichts damit zu tun wie man das sich hier
vorstellt mit dem bei rendering im web anwendungs kontext wird ja eigentlich meistens davon
gesprochen dass man javascript state umwandelt in den web anwendungs kontext und das ist ja auch
nicht der einzige schritt und das ist ja auch nicht der einzige schritt weil man kann ja auch
so ein bisschen was machen an einem griff und das html muss dann erst noch vom klag muss dann erst
noch vom client also vom browser wirklich gerendert werden zu was was was auf dem display angezeigt
werden kann also wenn du so willst gibt es eigentlich zwei rendering steps wobei der eine
streng genommen gar kein rendering ist nämlich dass javascript umwandeln in html das html wird
dann vom browser gerendert auf innen format was der grafikkarten anzeigen kann dass das glaube dass
Server-Seite und Client-Seite-Rendering zu vermischen, was Web-Anwendungen angeht, mit irgendwelchen Spielen, verwirrt eigentlich nur, weil es schon mal ziemlich unterschiedliche Sachen sind.
Ja, dann weiß ich, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Cute-Installation kaputt.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es an deinem Rechner liegt.
Lässiger Lord, danke schön für den Sub.
Relaxing, relaxing music from Super Mario Series haben wir heute als Playlist.
Äußerst, äußerst relaxing.
YouTube mag bzw. das Browser anzeigen können.
Kann ich dir zeigen? Nehmen wir mal das Video hier.
Gehen rüber in die VM.
Also stell dir vor, du lädst auf YouTube jetzt ein Video hoch.
Oh, guck mal, es gibt ein neues Release, interessant.
Tipp, find me later.
Ne, das ist höchstwahrscheinlich nicht das, was die Anwendung benutzt.
Die haben ja meistens ein, die bringen ja meistens Cute selbst mit.
Ne, dann bringt dir das nix, da hast du recht.
So, guck mal hier.
YouTube, ne, YouTube DLP minus F.
Warte.
So, und da siehst du die ganzen Formate.
Es ist minus Groß F.
Groß F.
Da siehst du die ganzen Formate, die YouTube anbietet hier.
So, und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du lädst ein Video hoch, MPEG-2, in einem MKV-Container.
Das kann kein Browser anzeigen.
Deswegen wandelt YouTube dein Video, falls das überhaupt so funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das supportet, aber ich denke mal schon, weil alte Aufnahmen, alte Fernsehaufnahmen sind oftmals MPEG-2-TS.
Und dann wandelt YouTube das Video um in ein Format, was Browser verstehen.
Zum Beispiel, ja, das ist relativ, relativ modern hier, Webm oder, oder, äh, MP4 ist Bescheid, MP4 ist eigentlich nur der Container.
Also eigentlich muss man das hier gucken, VP9 und AVC1, das ist ja der eigentliche Codec.
Und das ist, das, das ist im Fall von YouTube.
Die wandeln, die wandeln dein Source-Video-Material, egal in welchem Format es ist, um in eines dieser Formate hier, wo YouTube denkt, dass sie besonders gut im Browser funktionieren.
Und wenn ihr einen Browser habt, der beispielsweise VP9 kann, was glaube ich, alle sind außer Safari?
Da bin ich mir aber gar nicht so sicher, ob es nicht Safari auch noch kann, nicht kann mittlerweile.
Also du musst eigentlich standardmäßig davon ausgehen.
Dass Safari irgendwas nicht kann, wenn es relativ neu ist.
Oha, oha, gerade dabei sind.
Safari kann es natürlich nicht.
Aber Safari, Safari on iOS kann es zumindest, zumindest teilweise, ja.
Oh doch, hier, Moment, das ist, das ist AV1 nur.
Moment, das ist, ich hab mich sogar verguckt.
Wir wollen ja, ich will ja VP, äh, Webm VP9 gucken.
Okay, aber Safari on iOS kann es auch nur teilweise.
Das ist halt das Ding, warum ich manchmal sage, Safari, gerade...
Gerade der iOS-Safari ist der neue, ist der neue Internet Explorer, was moderne Technologien angeht.
Sie haben die letzten, aber wirklich auch nur die letzten, 1, 2, ja, das war es eigentlich, Jahre, wieder ein bisschen aufgeholt.
Weil ihnen aufgefallen ist, so langsam wird es richtig beschissen.
Aber Safari, es kommt doch eher auf die Grafikkarte an.
Ne, ne, ne, das kommt sicherlich auch auf die Grafikkarte an, aber der Browser muss es erstmal unterstützen.
Und Safari on iOS kann es anscheinend nur unter bestimmten Bedingungen.
Okay, guck, guck, Safari kann es nur für WebRTC-Verbindungen, was auch gut ist.
Jetzt konnten sie auch eine Weile nicht, weil, ähm, VP8 ist, glaube ich, der Standard für WebRTC-Verbindungen.
Die sollten alle Clients unterstützen.
Es ist halt schon bitter, ne, wenn du dir hier überlegst, dass, dass die anderen Browser das teilweise...
Guck mal, Firefox 23, ihr müsst euch das mal überlegen, Firefox 28 hatte das erste Mal Support dafür.
28.
Das ist von 2014, ja, und für Safari iOS hat es bis heute nicht richtig.
Ja, und, ähm, das hier kann Safari, glaube ich, auch nur mit Feature-Flag.
Ja, das hier kann nur auf, kann nur iPhone 15 Pro Max or later.
Kannst du also auch knicken.
Es ist in gewisser Weise verständlich, ja, dass sie sagen, hey, wir wollen da keine Software, keinen Software-Renderer mit bereitstellen, weil das einfach zu viel Akku frisst.
Aber es ist trotzdem scheiße, ja.
Es muss ja, es muss ja...
Es muss ja beidseitig unterstützt werden.
Also der Browser muss das unterstützen.
Und dann ist es zusätzlich noch sehr sinnvoll, wenn es deine Grafikkarte oder ein Hardware-Decoder kann, dass es eben nicht so sehr auf die CPU geht und damit auf die Akkuleistung.
Aber man sieht es hier schon, die sind schon echt ganz schön hinten dran.
Firefox kann es schon deutlich länger als Chrome, aber Firefox ist, was Video-Formate angeht, eh meistens recht, recht gut dabei.
So sieht es aus.
Da war aber eine super kreativ, oder?
Ich sag doch...
Ich sag nicht, dass es IE ist.
Ich sag, dass es der neue IE ist.
Wenn es einen Browser gibt bei aktuellen Entwicklungen, der bei vielen Webstandards und auch bei vielen Sachen, die schon lange etabliert sind, nicht richtig mitmacht oder wahnsinnig hinten dran ist, dann ist es von den drei eindeutig Safari.
Und die machen ja auch manchmal so ähnliche Sachen wie der Internet Explorer, eigene Dinge, obwohl es dafür Standards gibt.
Also ich finde, der Vergleich ist gar nicht so weit hergeholt.
Es ist noch nicht ganz so krass wie mit dem Internet Explorer, das stimmt.
Aber ich glaube, es muss auch nicht erst Internet Explorer, das Internet Explorer Niveau erreichen, um es mit Internet Explorer mal zu vergleichen.
Also Safari ist, wenn du die aktuellen Browser vergleichst, eindeutig der technisch rückständigste.
Und oftmals sogar auch noch die iOS-Version.
Die Desktop-Version kann ja manche Sachen, die die iOS... Umgedreht bestimmt auch, aber es hat Kacke.
Und das Problem ist daran, dass du nicht mal sagen kannst...
Ja, ich benutze jetzt einfach Chrome oder Firefox auf iOS-Geräten, dann geht das ja alles.
Denn, wie ihr sicherlich schon mitbekommen habt, gibt es kein Chrome und Firefox auf iOS.
Und dementsprechend könnt ihr auch kein Chrome und Firefox benutzen für mehr Features, die der Safari nicht kann.
Der Internet Explorer Nachfolger ist Edge, das ist richtig, aber Edge ist kein Problem, weil Edge auf Chrome basiert.
Gut, es gibt irgendwelche Leute, die...
Die müssen Edge für iOS rausbringen, falls es das gibt.
Aber das ist dann auch Safari.
Safari benutzt WebKit.
Und WebKit ist, glaube ich, das, was vor Urzeiten Chrome auch mal verwendet hat.
Aber ich bin mir da nicht sicher aus dem Kopf.
Chat, stimmt das?
War Chrome nicht auch ganz am Anfang mal WebKit?
Ja, genau, so war das.
Genau, Chrome ist aus...
Aber die sind schon lange nicht mehr reines WebKit.
Ja, Safari wahrscheinlich am längsten.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass es einen Browser geben wird, der immer topaktuell alle neuen Standards und Features supportet.
Aber muss man sagen, Chrome und Firefox sind da schon echt gut dabei.
Die unterstützen ja teilweise Features, für die noch gar kein richtiger Standard oder fertiger Standard und Implementierungsspezifikationen und alles existieren.
Die sind ja jetzt schon dabei.
Bis wir das mal in Safari sehen, dauert wahrscheinlich noch Jahrzehnte.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle und das ist eines der wenigen Sachen, dass die Safari tatsächlich kann.
Gucken wir mal.
Can I use...
Okay, ne, natürlich nicht.
Das sind Firefox, Firefox, Feature Flag.
Feature Flag.
Ne, Safari, Safari und Firefox.
Wobei ich Safari ungern als...
Wobei...
Also, ich klassifiziere Safari ungern als...
gängigen Browser. Die Realität
sagt aber, Safari ist ein gängiger
Browser, weil
iOS-Geräte sehr verbreitet sind
und Mac-Anzahlen halt auch
steigt, insofern...
Borek!
Ja, Chrome und Firefox auf iOS sind
Safari anders verpackt.
Wobei ich gelesen habe,
dass Apple das demnächst erlauben
möchte, andere Browser
neben Safari.
Frage ist, ob das schon passiert ist oder nicht.
So wie ich Apple kenne wahrscheinlich nicht,
die werden das rauszögern, bis es nicht mehr anders geht.
Aber da gab es mal vor einem
Jahr oder so News drüber, dass demnächst
Third-Party quasi
Browser-Engines auf iOS
erlaubt sind. Es ist ja nicht so, dass es
nicht gehen würde.
Ja, da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass es nicht gehen würde.
Selbstverständlich könnten Firefox und
Chrome ordentlich portieren auf iOS.
Aber Apple will das nicht.
Und dementsprechend kannst du keine App-Store-Distribution
machen und das ist für den Arsch.
Also in einem
der Guidelines von Apple steht halt drinnen,
als Browser-Engine muss Safari
verwendet werden.
Gucken wir mal, ob es dazu irgendwas
gibt. Okay,
Anfang des Jahres gab es einen
New iPhone Browsers on the
way without WebKit. Ja, schön, aber
ich glaube, da gibt es noch nichts.
Das letzte News
sind, sagen wir mal, ein Dreivierteljahr her.
Dass sich da die...
Wisst ihr, ich habe ja, was so
rechtliche Sachen angeht, nicht viel
Plan. Man könnte jetzt sagen, dass
es ja ähnlich wie damals Microsoft
Internet Explorer gebundelt
mit Windows. Der Unterschied ist
nur, dass
damals ganz
klar war,
dass es auf dem Desktop
eben neben Windows so gut wie nichts gab.
Apple wird wahrscheinlich argumentieren und sagen,
der Markt ist ja nicht iOS, sondern
Smartphone. Und bei Smartphone
gibt es aber genug
Konkurrenz und dementsprechend haben wir da keine
marktbeherrschende Stellung und wir müssen es auch nicht
machen. Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Windows war damals relativ unstrittig.
Das war irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 98%
aller Desktop-Computer hatten Windows.
Das war relativ klar zu sagen, ey,
Windows gebundelt mit
Internet Explorer heißt marktbeherrschende
Stellung, was auch immer. Bei Smartphones
ist das nicht zwangsläufig so.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass Apple da Bock drauf hat.
Und so wie es aussieht,
tut sich da auch nicht allzu viel.
Guckt, es gibt
im Februar gab es
immer mal wieder, immer mal wieder Meldungen.
Hier, die haben wir im Prinzip wieder alle
alle voneinander abgeschrieben,
weil das kam auch alles vor dem gleichen Tag.
So sieht's
aus. Chatgis.
Lass uns mal kurz
schauen, was trendet.
Auf Shithub.
Read it later solution for people who like reading.
Sowas finde ich
ganz praktisch.
Allerdings eher als,
sagen wir mal, etwas schlauere
Bookmark-Verwaltung mag ich sowas.
Ich benutze
ja öfters hier Pocket
von Firefox.
Aber so ganz glücklich bin ich damit
auch nicht, weil es halt
ein Cloud-Service ist. Das einzig
coole daran ist, du kannst es
halt automatisch synken
zwischen deinem Desktop-Browser und
deinem Handy.
Ich benutze
Pocket so gut wie nie zum Lesen.
Ich benutze es nur zum Suchen und zum Links
speichern.
Das finde ich mal eigentlich ganz interessant, was
das hier.
Das heißt Allesfresser, oder?
Das ist doch, was die Veganer
immer verwenden.
Allesfresser, ja.
Okay, sign it up.
Ich will das selbst hosten.
Docker Compose, okay.
Native iOS App.
Wenn es eine Native iOS App
ist, wo ist der
Store-Link?
Ah, tatsächlich. Nice.
Sogar im Store.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Wann gab es
die erste Version? Ich kenne das noch gar nicht.
Kann doch nicht so alt sein, oder?
Ah, doch.
2021. Ja, wobei, so alt ist es nicht.
Eigentlich eine
coole Sache.
Müssen wir uns mal angucken, was das kann.
Also
wichtig für mich ist halt, das ist im Prinzip
dann quasi eine
Linksammlung,
Sync-Service, wenn man es so will.
Was für mich wichtig ist, ist nicht so,
wie cool man da drin lesen kann, sondern dass die
Suche ordentlich funktioniert.
Das finde ich, das finde ich ganz
weil, weil
Bookmark Sync ist cool, aber viel
cooler ist Bookmark Sync inklusive
Suchmöglichkeiten über die Sachen,
die man gebookmarkt hat, zum Zeitpunkt
des Bookmarkens.
Das muss ich mir mal angucken. Das ist interessant.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
Wie hostet man das?
Getting started.
Oh, guck mal, gibt es gerade deutsche, deutscher Guide.
Speichern, lesen,
gucken wir mal, es gibt Firefly,
Firefox, Edge, Chrome.
Cool.
Finde ich, finde ich sehr nice.
Viel interessanter
ist, wie hostet man
das gescheit selbst? Da gab es, ich habe
in den Docker Compose gesehen.
Postgres, ja gut,
warum nicht?
API Backend, Web.
Ja.
Könnte man tatsächlich mal ausprobieren.
Wie synkt ihr dann eure Bilder
und Videos vom Handy zum Nass daheim?
Ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht.
Ich mache einfach alle paar Monaten Full Backup
von meinem, von meinem Smartphone.
Also von den, von den Data Folder
von meinem Smartphone und leg das
verschlüsselt auf mein Nass fertig.
Wenn man natürlich jetzt öfters mal mit
der Familie am Fernseher irgendwelche Bilder angucken
will, ist das natürlich, das ist nix.
Gehen tut es bestimmt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie.
Man sollte nicht anfangen, die Hersteller Cloud zu
verwenden, weil gerade die, die,
die Apple Cloud, das ist so ultra
Vendor Login alles.
Ich, ich verwende iOS auch echt so
leid, wie es geht.
Natürlich ein App Store Account,
Apple Account brauchst du.
Aber ich verwende keine Cloud,
keine, wie heißt das Ding?
I Cloud Storage selbst den selbst das Free
Storage Tier verwende ich nicht.
Über WiFi am besten.
Ja, also Backup, Backup über USB ist zwar
nicht das schnellste, aber dann baut's
halt eine halbe Stunde kein Ding.
Backup mache ich über USB.
Anstöpseln rüber, kopieren,
über USB mit, äh, iFuse, FS oder so.
Wie heißt das?
Hier, damit.
Damit maunte ich unter Linux mein,
mein iPhone und dann wird, werden die
Datenverzeichnisse rüber, rüber geschoben.
Da sagst du im Endeffekt einfach,
ja, das musst du alles gar nicht machen.
Wenn es ordentlich installiert,
musst du gar nicht machen.
Du sagst am Ende, am Ende sagst du einfach nur hier, ähm,
genau.
Nee.
Aber ich hab's irgendwo in meiner Shell-History.
Kannst du dein komplettes iPhone mounten in den Ordner und dann alles rüberkopieren.
Das ist tatsächlich der größte Vorteil von den eingebauten Funktionen, dass die einfach
funktionieren.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich auch das, warum sich das so gut verkauft.
Das funktioniert einfach.
Das ist ja auch das, was den, sagen wir mal, was 95% der Anbieter am wichtigsten ist, dass
sie sich nicht großartig drum kümmern müssen und es einfach funktioniert.
Ist der gleiche Grund, warum ich ab und zu iMessage verwende oder, oder FaceTime mit anderen Einstellern.
Das, du musst dir keine Gedanken machen, das funktioniert einfach.
Du hast die Telefonnummer der Leute, rufst an, machst FaceTime, Call, es geht halt einfach.
Also es hat, es hat manchmal durchaus seinen Charme, wenn es einfach geht.
Ist auch der Grund, warum ich mir fürs Fahrrad einen Garmin-Computer gekauft habe und einen
Garmin-Rücklicht.
Kannst du pairen miteinander und dann drückst du halt da auf den Knopf und es geht einfach.
So, also, was trennt es denn auf, auf ShitHub?
Das, das finde ich ganz interessant.
Das habe ich mir mal aufgeschrieben.
Vielleicht, vielleicht testen wir das sogar mal im, im Stream.
Mal gucken.
Äh, out, äh, AI, überspringen wir.
Irgendwelche Umfragen, Dinger.
Keine Ahnung, juckt mich nicht.
AI, äh, AI, Pi-Hole, Swift, Open Source Cross-Platform Alternative to AirDrop.
Okay, das ist cool.
Das Ding ist bloß, wahrscheinlich brauchen es beide Seiten und haben es dann nicht.
Aber coole Idee.
Guck mal, es gibt ein, das ist immer ein Zeichen, für das sie das ernst meinen, wenn sie was
im App-Store haben.
Ist aber cool, dass man airdroppen könnte zu einer Linux-Kiste.
Sehr praktisch, wenn man einfach nur mal irgendwie ein, ein Foto oder irgendein Video, was man
aufgenommen hat, rüber, rüberpacken will.
Gut, die Linux-Kiste braucht dann höchstwahrscheinlich Bluetooth, aber, boah, haben ja die meisten
Rechner heutzutage.
Coolify.
Was?
PHP, MonkHS, Alter.
Coolify-App.
Wie heißt das?
AI, oh.
Ganz ehrlich allein schon, weil das PHP ist, habe ich da wenig Bock drauf, wenn man da
was dran stricken will.
Wollen wir nicht.
AI-Local Pilot, AI juckt nicht.
uBlock.
Okay nice.
Alternative Front-End zu YouTube.
Moment, ohne, ohne Werbungszwang dann?
AI plays Pokemon?
Oder wie die Ami sagen, Pokémon?
Noch mehr, noch mehr YouTube-Stells.
Geht doch!
Ok, jetzt.
AI, AI, vermutlich, vermutlich auch AI, Enterprise Distributed Relational Database, können wir nicht einfach Postgres verwenden, High Performance Horizontal Scalability, da sieht man schon mal wie outdated die sind, anstatt es nicht einfach diagonal zu skalieren und sie sind kompatibel mit SQL Standards, krasse Dudes.
Wir können auch einfach Postgres verwenden, warum sollte ich das verwenden jetzt? Ah, weil Cloud Native und skalierbar, ja, okay, das ist natürlich mit Postgres, also Postgres tut sich ja ein bisschen schwer mit Multinode und super krassem rauf und runter skalieren, vieles kann einem durch den Postgres Operator in Kubernetes abgenommen werden, wobei ich persönlich immer noch der Meinung bin, Datenbank in Kubernetes ist meistens keine allzu geile Idee, aber kann man machen, man kann auch einfach den Manager,
Service verwenden von Google zum Beispiel, wobei sie sich glaube ich auch nicht wirklich großartig um Skalieren kümmern, ich weiß nicht, was es da für Cloud SQL Möglichkeiten gibt, außer, also bis jetzt fallen mir eigentlich bloß stärkere VMs ein, man könnte aber auch, ja, also wenn man wirklich den Anspruch hat, eine Multi-Write-Read-Datenbank zu haben in der Cloud, da gibt es ja sowas wie Cassandra DB, also das Problem beim Skalieren von Datenbanken ist ja gar nicht so sehr,
Multiple Read, sondern Multiple Write, so der klassische Ansatz Datenbanken, sagen wir mal, hochverfügbar und skalierbar zu machen ist ja, man hat, ja, man hat eine Datenbank, nennen wir es mal eine Datenbank-Klasse und davon hast du einen Masternode, das ist der einzige, der schreiben darf in die Datenbank und du hast mehrere quasi Read-Only-Nodes, die lesen können, das ist meistens kein großes Problem und oftmals auch genau der richtige Ansatz,
weil viel mehr gelesen wird aus der Datenbank, als geschrieben wird in die Datenbank, sollte das allerdings für diesen Anwendungsfall nicht passen, dann muss man sich was anderes überlegen und da bin ich, da bin ich nicht so sehr drin im Database-Game, um mich da groß auszukennen, wie man das beispielsweise mit Postgres gescheit machen würde.
Ich persönlich würde vermuten, dass es mit Postgres auch nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad überhaupt möglich ist, weil es muss ja seinen Grund haben, warum sich die letzten Jahre über noch neben Postgres und den klassischen,
System, so, so Cloud-Native-Datenbank-Sachen etabliert haben. Also das erste, was mir einfallen würde, ist, glaube ich, CassandraDB oder was, CouchbaseDB, ich glaube, es war CassandraDB für, für weltweit verteilte Datenbanken.
Moment, was? Customized-Firmware für die Nintendo Switch? Was ist das hier? Was gibt's hier? Switch, Leute, eigene Switch, Switch-Champ, Firmware-Implementierung, Incoming, ja.
Okay, Nintendo darf das nicht benutzen? Nee.
Nintendo, Nintendo darf das benutzen, uneingeschränkt, oder?
Ich hab die erste Switch-Version. Ich könnte theoretisch, ich könnte theoretisch meine Switch-Hackerman.
Ich ver, okay, also, der Axt-Mörder-Panda möchte was wissen, und zwar, er versucht hier gerade parallel einen neuen Router aufzusetzen und will vor, die IP-Adresse gleichzusetzen wie die meisten meines aktuellen Routers.
Haben den hier einfach lokal am Laptop eingesteckt, aber über Browser drauf zugreifen funktioniert einfach nicht.
Wie finde ich den denn jetzt?
Wahrscheinlich hat sich dein Router per DHCP in eine IP gezogen von deinem schon bestehenden Router, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Die, die einfachste Variante dürfte sein, du stöpselst dein Rechner direkt an den Router dran.
Ach nee, Moment.
Du hast, ja, ja, ja, das, das kannst du machen.
Dann musst du, dann musst du ins Handbuch gucken, was das Ding für eine Default-IP hat.
Weil du kannst auch, du kannst auch IP, IP-Ad oder IF-Config machen und mal gucken, ob dein Rechner...
...der an diesem Router hängt, schon eine IP bekommen hat.
Wenn nämlich dein Rechner schon eine IP bekommen hat, dann hat er höchstwahrscheinlich dann auch den Router als Gateway drinstehen.
Mach mal, mach mal IP-Ad oder IF-Config oder, äh, IP-Config oder so.
Ja, wenn er die bekommen hat, dann hat der Router per DHCP nichts verteilt.
Aber die meisten Router geben sich standardmäßig irgendeine, irgendeine Default-IP aus, fragt mich nicht.
192.168.
155.1 oder so.
Ja, manche kommen aber auch damit hoch.
Aber die meisten, die meisten Consumer-Dinger nicht.
Ja, WLAN aus, natürlich, ne, das sollst du schon exklusiv dann den Router benutzen.
Guck mal, guck mal IF-Config, ob der, ob der was bekommen hat.
Ob dein, ob dein Laptop schon eine IP gekriegt hat vom Router.
Ansonsten resetterst du den Router nochmal, lässt ihn neu starten und guckst aber dann, was er kriegt.
Und dann bleibt dir eigentlich nichts anderes übrig, außer Default-IP im Handbuch nachzugucken.
Und sollte dein Laptop...
Wenn du keine DHCP bekommen vom Router, dann musst du dein Laptop, die Netzwerkkarte, eine IP aus dem Default-Netzwerk geben.
Und auf die Default-IP vom Router gehen.
Immer ein bisschen...
Schick mal das Modell.
Wir gucken jetzt mal.
Wir gucken jetzt mal zusammen ins Handbuch hier und streamen.
Was, was ist das für ein Router?
So.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Was können wir uns denn heute angucken?
Ja, Maurice hat ein neues Video, den gucke ich ja immer gerne.
Microsoft kauft endlich Blizzard und kann es nur besser werden, oder?
Ehrlich gesagt, man würde jetzt pauschal denken, es kann ja nur besser werden, aber man darf nicht vergessen,
auch Microsoft und auch der Xbox-Chef und die ganzen Manager da, die sind jetzt auch nicht unbedingt bekannt dafür,
so die puren Menschenfreunde zu sein.
So, also, TP-Link, wir gucken jetzt mal zusammen, Chatge.
TP-Link AC1750.
Archer.
Ah, okay, ich dachte, du hast so einen Stealth-Bomber-Router, aber der sieht ja noch halbwegs normal aus.
So, ähm, Support.
Ja, ich hoffe mal V5.
Wo haben die das Handbuch, Leute?
Äh, Manual.
Wo ist es denn?
Seht ihr irgendwas?
Hier, User Guide.
Okay, User Guide.
Dann lasst uns doch mal zusammen reingucken.
On-Panel, Back-Panel, Setup.
Login, Connect your Hardware, Position your Router, Connect your Router.
Okay, da haben wir es doch.
Position your Router, Connect to your Router.
So.
If your Internet comes from...
Blablabla.
Blablabla, das wollen wir doch noch gar nicht.
Modem.
Was wollen die denn hier?
Hier, das ist das.
Okay, das hast du wahrscheinlich, das hast du wahrscheinlich gemacht.
Kein Internet, also keine IP.
Das hat das eine mit dem anderen nichts zu tun.
Du kriegst eine lokale IP von deinem Router an deinem Notebook, ob der Internet hat oder nicht, das ist egal.
Turn off Wi-Fi on your Computer.
Ja, das ist gut.
Wi-Fi off, off turn.
Und dann einstecken.
Okay, ja, das ist easy.
Und dann?
Und dann solltest du eigentlich schon, solltest du eigentlich bei DHCP eine IP von dem Router kriegen.
Und dann kannst du auf tp-link-wifi.net, gut, ja, das ist die Frage, ob da die Auflösung richtig funktioniert, wenn irgendwas anderes nicht tut.
Also als erstes würde ich tatsächlich Wi-Fi ausschalten, Laptop einschalten, Router neu, also Laptop einstöpseln, Router neu starten und dann per if-config gucken, ob mein Interface eine IP hat.
Also, wir müssen mal gucken, wie das hier auflöst.
Aber das ist das Erste.
Wi-Fi ausschalten am Router, äh, nicht am Router, Alter.
Wi-Fi ausschalten am Notebook, Notebook einstöpseln an Router, Router neu starten und dann nach 20, 30 Sekunden gucken.
Ja, anscheinend schon.
Es scheint default zu sein, zumindest laut Handbuch.
Und dann if-config gucken, ob das Interface eine IP gekriegt hat.
Und mal schauen, ob die Link-LEDs auch überhaupt leuchten zwischen Router und Laptop.
Genau, und wenn es gebraucht ist, einmal resetten.
Ja, also resetten auf jeden Fall, wenn er nicht neu ist.
Der Router.
Den musst du in LAN einstecken, dein Notebook, nicht in WAN.
Wi-Fi ausschalten am Notebook.
LAN-Port 1.
In den Laptop.
Und dann if-config am Laptop gucken, ob er eine IP gekriegt hat.
Oder IP-config, wie auch immer, ob du unter Linux oder Windows oder Mac bist.
Wahrscheinlich unter Windows.
Unter Windows ist es IP-config.
Und es ist nicht einfach nur IP-config, sondern Chat, wie ist es unter Windows?
IP-config?
Ich glaube IP-config minus A.
Oder, nee, all, all, genau.
IP-config slash all.
Ich wusste das natürlich und wollte nur checken, ob der Chat das auch weiß.
Ja, genau.
Und dann kannst du gucken, ob dein Interface eine IP hat.
Wenn dein Interface eine IP bekommen hat von dem Router, dann sieht es gut aus.
Dann kannst du weitermachen.
So, also, Shit-Up-Trends haben wir, glaube ich, durch.
War nichts, war nichts sonderlich Spannendes.
Lass uns gerade nochmal just for fun gucken, ob es in der .NET-Welt irgendwelche spannenden Sachen gibt.
Nope.
Ein DNS-Server in .NET, warum denn das?
Moment, habe ich den nicht auch mal verwendet?
Chat-Gate.
Habe ich nicht mal irgendwas gebaut, wo ich selbst einen DNS-Server gebraucht habe in meinem .NET-Code?
Und da haben wir den verwendet?
Was war das denn nochmal?
Ich weiß es, die Wetterstation, das Display von der Wetterstation hat China-Chinesen-DNS-Auflösung gebraucht.
Und die habe ich gefaked mit dem DNS-Server hier.
Ja, genau, den habe ich schon mal benutzt sogar.
Switch-Emulator.
Farming Steamcast.
Unity.
Osu.
Weeps in.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Tiling Window Manager.
For Windows.
Oh je, Leute.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Inspired by i3 und Polybar.
Wann gab es das erste Release davon?
Das kenne ich noch gar nicht, wie alt ist denn das?
2021, okay, das ist auch noch nicht so alt.
Das schreibe ich mir auch mal auf, das probieren wir irgendwann mal aus.
Aber.
Aber nicht in meinem Host-System, sondern in der VM.
I3 für, das wird was, äh.
Sieht auf jeden Fall cool aus.
Pogu?
Gefällt mir jetzt eigentlich auf den ersten Blick mal eigentlich ganz gut.
Keine Taskleiste, ja, umso besser, oder?
Ich glaube, das ist das Letzte, was man braucht.
Interessant.
Das probieren wir mal aus.
Da bin ich gespannt, ob das taugt.
Jetzt.
IELTS Spy.
Ich dachte, es wird nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
Background Jobs, AP.
Naja, natürlich nur, um Linux-Distributionen runterzuladen.
Oh, Maui.
Da warte ich immer noch auf die Meldung von Microsoft, dass Ball eingestellt wird.
Was ist damit?
Da war ich beeindruckt.
Geht was, Peppi?
Osu.
Weeps in.
Solltest du dir mal angucken.
Ja, aber nicht on Stream.
Warum soll ich für Pipe Video on Stream angucken?
Couch Base.
Ich...
Datenbank ist halt nicht so das, wo ich richtig Plan von hab.
Der hat seit sechs Jahren mindestens einen Commit jeden Tag.
Krasser Dude.
Eindeutig fast so gut wie der Fiat Champ.
Was macht eigentlich, wo wir gerade dabei sind?
Shit.
Last week.
Oh, shit.
Oh, Mann.
Ich habe keinen Kopf gerade groß weiterzumachen, ne?
Ja, nicer Dude.
Wie geht's dir?
Was das ist?
Was?
Genau, Smarthome-Integration für Fiat, Fiat und Dodge, Trucks und Alfa Romeo und Jeep, glaube ich.
Aber hauptsächlich, aber hauptsächlich für Fiat, weil ich habe das für meinen eigenen Fiat gebaut.
Das Ding ist halt...
Ja, wie gesagt, ich wurde gestern auf dem Fahrradweg umgefahren.
Und was macht dein Laptop?
So, dann lasst uns mal schauen.
Was können wir uns denn jetzt angucken?
Was ist das denn?
Also, ich habe einen...
Das ist ein Exempel, wie das bei mir im Home Assistant jetzt aussieht.
Ich habe einen Fiat 500e.
Und da kannst du ein paar Werte von abrufen.
Leider kann man das halt nicht direkt vom Auto...
Ich bin Fahrrad gefahren und wurde von einem Auto umgefahren auf dem Fahrradweg.
Und...
Das bekommt man nicht direkt vom Auto, sondern über die...
Naja, sagen wir mal, inoffizielle API von Fiat.
Was ist das?
Password Storage Tierlist.
Encryption, Hashing, Salting, BC...
Moment.
Das eine und das andere...
Also, das ist nicht entweder oder.
Also, du kannst was hashen, okay?
Dann kannst du es nicht encrypten.
Das lasse ich mir noch gefallen, ja?
Aber das ergänzt das nur.
Also, ich würde nicht unbedingt sagen, dass das eine Tierlist ist.
Sondern unterschiedlichste Sachen.
Naja, wer weiß.
Wer weiß.
Was YouTube da denkt jetzt.
Oder der Ersteller.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Top Recruiter Gehalt.
Er ist Key Account Manager für Zeitarbeit Fachkräfte.
Lohnt sich das?
Oh ja, das gucken wir mal.
Personalverschacherungsdudes.
Na, eigentlich sollte man nicht unbedingt Passwörter...
Ne, encryptet man nicht Passwörter, sondern hasht Passwörter.
Und das mit einem Sort dabei.
Und hashen hat mit Encryption nichts zu tun.
Jetzt bräuchten wir Algorithmen verstehen.
Der können uns das alles ganz super fachmännisch korrekt erklären.
Ich kann es euch nur 90% korrekt erklären.
Hashen ist ja keine Encryption.
Weil hashen ist one way und Encryption ist, ja, fair und entschlüsselbar.
Also, in beide Richtungen.
Ja gut, du kannst das...
Du kannst den Hash encrypted über das Passwörter.
Übertragen, ja.
Du kannst auch das Passwort encrypten und übertragen.
Aber das eine hat mit dem anderen halt nichts zu tun.
Du steckst den Salt und das Passwort in deine Hash-Funktion rein.
Und du brauchst den Salt im Klartext.
Und ja, den Hash-Algorithmus.
Dass du es auf der anderen Seite auch überprüfen kannst.
Weiterer Grund dafür, warum man keine Encryption und irgendwelche Security-Sachen selbst programmieren sollte,
sondern irgendwas Fertiges nimmt.
Nicht, dass sie nicht auch Probleme haben können.
OpenSSL hatte jetzt die letzten Jahre über ja auch die ein oder anderen Sicherheitslücken.
Aber die Chancen sind deutlich geringer, als wenn man selbst was macht.
Ich guck das Video jetzt aber gar nicht.
Wir gucken uns jetzt an.
Top Recruiter Gehalt.
Er ist Key Account Manager für Zeit.
Was genau macht eigentlich...
Das habe ich jetzt schon öfters gehört.
Und eigentlich würde man sagen, ja, man könnte es ja mittlerweile wissen.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht, was ein Key Account Manager eigentlich genau ist.
Was ist...
Okay, was ist ein Key...
Okay, ein Key Account Manager, CAM,
sind für die Betreuung der wichtigsten Kunden zuständig.
In der Regel sind es die sogenannten Schlüsselkunden,
die für den meisten Umsatz...
Ah ja, ah ja, okay, also sprich...
Sagen wir mal,
wir als relativ große Versicherung in Deutschland,
sind irgendwie Premium-Kunde bei Google zum Beispiel, ja?
Dann wäre der Typ,
der sich bei Google um uns kümmert,
der Key Account Manager für uns.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Warum ist es denn eine Führungskraft?
Das eine hat doch mit der anderen gar nichts zu tun.
Na gut, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Ich hoffe...
Ja, das ist doch gut, je nach Position,
sonst muss dann ja auch immer ordentlich Kohle rumkommen.
Also...
Dann schieß mal los mit eurem neuen Projekt.
Also die ersten Worte, die immer folgen, sind natürlich Sklavenhandel.
Was habt ihr...
Ja, ja, na gut.
Wenn man sich manche Personalverschacherungsdinge anguckt,
vielleicht rein rechtlich gesehen nicht,
aber es hat, würde ich mal sagen, schon die ein oder anderen parallel.
Was habt ihr denn mit der Frau vereinbart, Kamil?
Weil das ist ja wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr wenig Geld.
Das kann man fast nicht machen.
Ich finde auch, dass...
Okay, lass mal kurz...
Dann schieß mal los mit eurem neuen Projekt.
Also die ersten Worte, die immer folgen, sind natürlich Sklavenhandel.
Was habt ihr denn mit der Frau vereinbart, Kamil?
Weil das ist ja wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr wenig Geld.
Erst mal schön mit Goldkettchen.
Das kann man fast nicht machen.
Ich finde auch, dass das Gehalt, das ich im Monat bekomme,
im Vergleich zu jemandem, der eine wichtigere Arbeit macht,
teilweise auch zu hoch ist.
Okay.
Wenn man wichtige Arbeit irgendwie definieren würde,
zu...
Ja, wenn man mal sich das im Verhältnis angucken würde,
was Leute beispielsweise im Altersheim und so leisten,
so für die, wie soll man sagen, so für die Allgemeinheit,
dann würde ich sagen, ja, dann verdiene ich auch zu viel.
Das würde ich auch unterschreiben, dass manche...
Aber ich muss sagen, ich finde den Vergleich immer ein bisschen problematisch,
weil das heißt ja nicht, dass der eine weniger verdienen muss,
damit der andere mehr verdienen muss.
Man könnte einfach alle Leute ordentlich bezahlen.
Aber bei manchen Jobs hängt halt einfach,
und jetzt mal keck Business-Speak,
hängt halt wahrscheinlich einfach nicht genug Geld dran,
als dass man eben das Geld in die Hand nimmt.
Für solche Stellen.
Ich denke, wir können alle relativ unstrittig sagen,
dass es für, ja, für die Allgemeinheit enorm wichtig ist,
dass wir Leute haben, die in der Pflege arbeiten,
im Krankenhaus arbeiten und sonst was.
Und wenn man jetzt sagen würde, was ist wichtiger?
Jemand, der sich um die Opas im Altersheim kümmert
oder jemand, der dafür sorgt, dass bei einer Versicherung,
bei einem Ausfall die Server schnell wieder laufen,
könntest du sagen, ja klar, der Typ, der im Altersheim arbeitet.
Aber...
keck Business ist das nicht so.
Weil wenn du mal überlegst, wo da mehr Geld dranhängt,
also sagen wir mal so aus, wie soll man sagen,
aus sozialer, menschlicher Sicht, ne?
Kann man das, denke ich, kann man das relativ einstimmig sagen.
Aber aus keck Business-Sicht ist das nicht so.
Weil der Opa im Altersheim kostet Geld und bringt kein Geld.
Und wenn du guckst, was so ein Systemausfall verursacht
in Millionenhöhe, dann ist es halt klar,
dass man sich lieber jemand hinsetzt, der sich darum kümmert,
als den Leuten im Altersheim gescheit Geld zu bezahlen.
Was kacke ist, aber aus Business-Sicht irgendwie die,
sagen wir mal, die Entwicklung vielleicht nicht rechtfertigt,
aber irgendwie noch halbwegs erklärt.
Und ich denke mir halt immer, also ich habe mir so Fragen
auch schon öfters gestellt, so nach dem Motto, Alter, guck mal,
du verdienst so viel Kohle im Vergleich zu jemand,
der wirklich wichtige Sachen so für die Allgemeinheit macht.
Aber die Hintergedanken sind halt, irgendjemand hat das ja mal
sich überlegt und gesagt, ja, wir geben das Geld dafür aus.
Okay, und man überlegt sich zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt einen Job
in der IT hat und vielleicht bei einer größeren Bank
oder bei einer Versicherung oder bei irgendwas,
wo wirklich viel Geld dranhängt.
Dann hat sich irgendjemand dort mal überlegt, okay,
ein Systemausfall kostet uns 20 Millionen am Tag.
Ich sage jetzt einfach, keine Ahnung,
keine realen Bezüge, Leute.
Irgendjemand, ich sage, denkt mir jetzt einfach was aus.
Irgendjemand hat sich dort mal überlegt, okay,
ein Systemausfall kostet uns 20 Millionen am Tag.
Das heißt, wenn wir da jetzt drei Leute hinsetzen,
selbst wenn die nicht so viel machen,
wenn die einfach nur dafür sorgen, dass im Fall der Fälle,
und sagen wir mal, wir haben einen Ausfall so alle zwei Jahre mal,
und wenn die nur da sitzen und im Fall der Fälle dafür sorgen,
dass das System nicht einen Tag weg ist,
sondern nur zwei Stunden, dann hat sich das schon gelohnt.
Das wird irgendjemand da gerechnet haben und feststellen,
okay, das ist sinnvoll und wir brauchen gescheite Leute
und buttert da richtig Geld rein.
Das ist das, was bei einer Bank oder bei einer Versicherung
garantiert passiert, was im Altersheim so halt nicht ist.
Daher kommt halt, denke ich, auch irgendwie diese Diskrepanz
zwischen dem, was man eben für die Allgemeinheit wichtig ansieht,
und trotzdem der irgendwie relativ geringen Bezahlung.
Wobei man sagen muss, das ist gar nicht mehr so.
Habe ich letztens einen Artikel drüber gelesen.
Es ist anscheinend hauptsächlich dort, wo die Leute festangestellt sind
in der Pflege und im Altersheim,
dass dort die Löhne wirklich mega beschissen sind.
Und was ich jetzt auch schon öfters gelesen habe,
wenn man dort flexibel ist und bei einer Zeitarbeitsfirma arbeitet,
dass man richtig ordentlich gut Kohle machen kann.
Das heißt natürlich dann auch, man springt irgendwo ein
für zwei Wochen in einem Altersheim in Stuttgart
und dann irgendwie zwei Wochen später in einem Altersheim in Mannheim.
Ich weiß nicht, wie krass das läuft
oder ob das auch mal ein halbes Jahr, Jahr läuft.
Ist sicherlich auch nicht jedermanns und jederfraus Sache.
Aber da, zumindest was man so liest, kann man wohl auch richtig Kohle verdienen,
wenn man das macht.
So flicks.
So flexibel.
Da kann man wohl richtig Geld verdienen.
Also man kann glaube ich pauschal gar nicht sagen,
dass es schlecht bezahlt ist.
Wenn man festangestellt ist, dann ist es wohl echt beschissen.
Das ist genauso wie beispielsweise letztens
Frau vor dem Kollegium, die arbeitet im Kindergarten und so.
Das ist auch, wenn du das mal vergleichst,
ist der Witz, was die Leute da verdienen.
Na gut, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Hi, mein Name ist Eike, ich bin 29 Jahre alt
und gemeinsam mit meinem Team rekrutieren wir Fachkräfte
aus Osteuropa für den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt.
Morgen.
Geht's gut?
Das ist hier so unsere...
Auf das Büro hätte ich ja gar keinen Bock, da irgendwie mit, keine Ahnung,
zwölf Leuten im Büro zu hocken und du kriegst mit den ganzen Tag
wieder deine Kollegen telefonieren und sowas.
Da kann ich mich nicht konzentrieren bei.
Recruiting Abteilung soweit.
Die beiden sind für Kroatien zuständig und teilweise auch Bulgarien.
Unsere beiden Mädels hier machen die rumänische Flanke soweit
und die beiden sind hier für Ungarn zuständig.
Wir rekrutieren halt eben Fachkräfte aus Osteuropa,
allerdings halt eben zur Personalüberlassung.
Bedeutet, wir suchen beispielsweise Schweizer aus Rumänien oder aus Polen
oder aus Tschechien oder aus Slowakei oder ähnliches,
die dann bei unseren Endkunden eingesetzt werden.
Die Endkunden bezahlen wahrscheinlich richtig Kohle.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was denen ihr Satz ist oder was sie davon abschreiben,
so irgendwie mal mindestens drei Monatsgehälter oder sowas.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was da üblich ist.
Das wird ordentlich unterbrochen.
Das wird ordentlich oder permanent wahrscheinlich pro Monat.
Es wird permanent Asche kriegen.
Im Prinzip wird wahrscheinlich hinten beim eigentlichen Arbeiter
auch noch ganz gut was ankommen im Vergleich zu Rumänien.
Ja, aber im Vergleich zu direkt wahrscheinlich nicht.
Am Ende könnte ich mir vorstellen, lohnt sich das aber für alle.
Am Ende könnte ich mir echt vorstellen, lohnt sich das für alle.
Vielleicht sehe ich das auch zu blauäugig.
Also ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen,
sonst würden es die Leute ja nicht machen.
Und ausgelegt ist es so,
dass nach zwölf Monaten eine Übernahme ins Stammpersonal erfolgt,
weil das so Handwerksberufe sind,
die in Deutschland mittlerweile zu selten ausgeübt werden oder auch erlernt werden.
Ich koordiniere im Endeffekt das Ganze hier.
Meine Abteilung ist die Rechte hier hinten.
Um 9 Uhr würden wir uns kurz via Zoom mit unserem Niederlassungsleiter...
Aha, Zoom.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich weniger mag.
Teams oder Zoom?
Ja, es ist Zoom.
Ich mag Zoom weniger.
Teams geht mir auch auf den Sack.
Aber Zoom, jedes Mal, wenn ich mich damit...
Wenn ich nur in einen Call rein muss, habe ich schon Anfälle.
In Polen zusammensetzen.
Da müssen wir einen neuen Auftrag finalisieren für den Bereich Zahntechnik.
Das ist für uns auch komplett neu.
Deswegen mal schauen, was da rauskommt.
Wir sind viel im Bereich Troubleshooting dann auch unterwegs.
Wenn irgendwas bewerber- oder mitarbeiterseitig nicht klappt
oder kundenseitig auch nicht klappt,
ja, wir gehen jetzt kurz rüber in den Besprechungsraum.
Hallo.
Wenn er sagt Fachkräfte aus Osteuropa,
das erinnert mich, wo ich beim Elektriker angerufen habe,
hier bei mir im Ort.
Als ich mir...
Ich wollte mir so ein Ladegerät für das Elektroauto in den Hof bauen lassen.
Und da habe ich angerufen beim Elektriker, hier um die Ecke.
Habe ich einfach geguckt, Google Maps.
Und das Erste...
Bei dem Ersten, wo ich angerufen habe,
ging einer dran mit einem super krassen, weiß ich nicht,
russischen, ukrainischen, polnischen Akzent.
Ich kann das gar nicht richtig einordnen.
Und das Erste...
Ich habe dem erklärt...
Ohne Scheiß, das Erste, was der geantwortet hat, war,
als ich ihm erklärt habe, was ich haben will,
also erstmal hat er gemeint, Chef nicht da oder sowas.
Und da habe ich ihm gesagt, ja, und das und das.
Und das Erste, was ich von ihm gehört habe, ist,
das wird teuer.
Da habe ich mir schon gedacht, okay, ihr habt weder was angeguckt noch,
wisst ihr genau, was Sache ist.
Das wird denn teuer.
Und ich habe gesagt, okay, vielleicht rufe ich doch lieber woanders an.
Latunox, danke für den Sub.
Okay.
Dann habe ich bei einem anderen angerufen hier um die Ecke
und das war deutlich seriöser.
Der hat gesagt, ich könnte nächste Woche mal kurz vorbeikommen, gucken.
Hat er geguckt, hat gesagt, hier, easy, können wir nächste Woche Freitag machen.
Das ging tatsächlich erstaunlicherweise sehr schnell.
Hat dann einen von seinen Jungs vorbeigeschickt
und der hat da zwei Stunden gebaut
und dann hatte ich eine Ladestation im Hof.
Die Stühle sehen äußerst unergonomisch aus, ja.
Kamil, grüß dich.
Ja.
Wir sind vom Bayerischen Rundfunk.
Beste Antwort.
Hallo, wir sind vom Bayerischen Rundfunk.
Eigentlich habe ich gar keinen Bock auf euch, kann es aber nicht sagen.
Ja, passt soweit.
So.
Dann schieß mal los mit eurem neuen Projekt.
Wie viel Kilo?
Elf.
Weil elf musst du nicht groß genehmigen lassen.
Finalisieren.
Ich heiße Martina.
Ich kann dir einfach ein leckeres Lauf zu senden.
Okay.
Habt ihr über den Preis schon gesprochen oder was die Dame verdienen soll?
Ja, vor allem haben wir was kurz gesprochen.
Zwei, sechs.
Zwei, fünf.
Vor allem müssen...
Es geht uns...
Okay, das ist ja echt nicht viel.
Okay, je nachdem für was, ja?
Ja.
Also, für die ist es wahrscheinlich viel.
Kennst du EVCC?
Das sagt mir was.
Ich kann es jetzt gerade nicht so wirklich zu...
Das sagt mir aber auf jeden Fall was in dem Kontext, ja?
Unbedingt eine Unterkünfte in der Gegend.
Sie wird einfach ohne Auto anreisen.
Aber muss ich nochmal nachfragen.
Gut.
Okay.
Super.
Danke dir.
Mach's gut.
Ciao.
Ciao, ciao, ciao.
Spannende Geschichte mit der Nummer.
Ja.
Wenn sie ohne Auto kommt, wird es echt herausfordernd, glaube ich.
Der Unterkunft in Stuttgart, der ist ja so schon sportlich, aber dann noch ohne Auto.
Also im Endeffekt ist es so, dass wir bei einer Personalüberlassung den künftigen Mitarbeitern
eine Wohnung...
Wie viel verdienst du im Monat?
Zu viel?
Beziehungsweise...
Also, nicht wirklich zu viel.
Aber im Vergleich...
Zu dem, was ich eben gesagt habe, wahrscheinlich zu viel.
Können wir zur Verfügung stellen.
Bei uns als Standard immer Einzelzimmer.
Ist als Lohnbestandteil drin.
Bedeutet, wir bezahlen die Unterkunft und ziehen es dann den Mitarbeitern vom Lohn im Endeffekt
dann ab.
Ich schau mal nach die Unterkunft erst mal.
Du machst das soweit alles fix, klär das soweit.
Ja.
Und dann können wir ja weitergehen.
Also, ohne den Zweier zu nahe treten zu wollen.
Das erste, was mir einfällt, wenn ich ihn hier mit dem Goldkettchen sehe oder dem Silberkettchen,
ist, es wirkt so ein bisschen wie Russisch in Kasso, oder?
Wenn er vor der Tür steht.
Du musst jetzt bezahlen.
Hat irgendwie was davon.
Ja, weitergehen.
Ja.
Okay.
Gut.
Bis gleich.
Tschüss.
Gut.
Also, da würde ich auch bezahlen, wenn er vor der Tür steht.
Können wir uns mal kurz den Vertrieb anschauen bei uns?
Da gibt es gerade ein paar Problemchen, aber die kriegen wir auch gelöst.
Bei uns hat ein Kunde jetzt gerade vier Leute abgemeldet wegen Auftragseinbruch.
Unser Ziel ist es, dass wir die Kandidaten, die jetzt ohne Auftrag dastehen, schnellstmöglich
wieder in Lohn und Brot bringen.
Wir haben jetzt vier Lackiervorbereiter oder Lackierhelfer, oder?
Naja, Chat würde ich nicht sagen.
Hört sich vielleicht etwas...
Ich finde, die Aufmachung sieht alles vielleicht ein bisschen unseriös aus, aber ich glaube,
dass das ein legit, wie soll man sagen, ein vollkommen normales in der heutigen Zeit Anwendungs-,
nee, nicht Anwendungs-, Geschäftstätigkeitsfeld ist.
Die suchen halt händeringend Leute.
Und irgendwo müssen die Leute herkommen.
Und nachdem jetzt der Handwerksbetrieb hier um die Ecke nicht nach Rumänien fährt und
da sagt, Jungs, wollt ihr mal bei uns anfangen?
Ich finde, das ist ein vollkommen normales Tätigkeitsfeld.
Dass da sicherlich viel, ja, vielleicht fragwürdige Sachen teilweise laufen, nicht so zum Vorteil
von denen, die am Ende da anfangen, mag alles sein, aber so das Feld an sich ist doch vollkommen
in der heutigen Zeit vollkommen normal, ja.
Würde ich gar nicht sagen.
Sag mal.
Ein bisschen sicherlich.
Ich weiß, ich weiß zum Beispiel damals, als ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe,
dort wurden auch Leute quasi vermietet an, ja, Unternehmen in Frankfurt zum Beispiel,
die sich dort dann um IT-Sachen gekümmert haben.
Und wenn man dort geguckt hat, was die dort für einen bezahlt haben versus das, was man kriegt,
war natürlich ein riesengroßer Unterschied.
Aber es gibt ja nach wie vor Unternehmen, die suchen Leute und es gibt Leute, die wollen das machen.
Und die vermitteln das.
Das würde ich jetzt nicht pauschal sagen, dass das irgendwas ja un...
Wie könnte man das nennen?
Pauschal was unseriöses ist.
Also, die machen halt was, was gemacht werden muss.
Sehr gutes Deutsch als Holztechniker.
Und dass sie dabei was verdienen wollen, ist ja auch okay.
Wenn da irgendwo im Lebensmittelbereich oder in der Pharmaindustrie schon mal gearbeitet
hat, wäre es super.
Also wir schauen halt eben.
Wir haben Kunden, die haben gewisse Voraussetzungen beispielsweise.
Es wird B1-Deutsch vorausgesetzt.
Es wird eine Erfahrung im Lebensmittel-Pharma-Chemie-Bereich vorausgesetzt.
Das kommt immer ganz auf die Kundenanforderungen drauf an, wo wir die Leute platzieren können.
Ja.
Ne, die bewerben wir gar nicht.
Also, der Ablauf ist so, dass unser Kunde uns einen gewissen Stundensatz für jede Produktivstunde dann uns bezahlt.
Oh, krass!
Pro Stunde!
Alter, das...
Hohohoho!
Das wird teuer, ey!
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, die kriegen pauschal irgendwie ein, zwei, drei Monatsgehälter oder so.
Oder irgendwie eine Prämie oder so.
Dass da nochmal pro Stunde draufgehauen wird.
Alter, das geht ja mal richtig ins Geld, ey!
Und davon, da kann man dann auch ausgehen, dass wahrscheinlich ein nicht unerheblicher Teil beim Vermittler landet.
Also, dass wahrscheinlich der, der die Leute bekommt, echt ordentlich bezahlen muss dafür.
Und derjenige, der was bekommt, der wird wahrscheinlich auch gut Geld bekommen für rumänische Verhältnisse.
Aber ein Großteil dessen an Differenz landet beim Vermittler.
Ist ja auch okay, ne? Die müssen ja auch Geld verdienen.
Aber das wird echt teuer, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Dann lass ich dich mal in Ruhe.
Also, da machen wir schon drei, vier Pausen, würde ich sagen, am Tag, wo man kurz einen Espresso dann zu uns nimmt.
Ah, ich trink...
Ich hab's grad schon...
Ich find das immer wieder...
Ich find das immer wieder komisch, weil gerade...
Ich hab das...
Ich hab das Gefühl, gerade in IT, alle saufen Kaffee und trinken auch Cola und Energydrinks und sowas.
Sich bei uns auf der Arbeit auch.
Ich bin der Einzige, gefühlt, der weder Kaffee noch Energydrinks noch Cola zu sich nimmt.
Gar nix.
Ich trink eigentlich nur Wasser.
Ich hab schon gelesen, ja, was haben wir denn für ein Problem?
Ich will mit dem Auto anreisen, aber mit Partner und kleinen Haustieren.
Problem Nummer zwei, er zahlt nach Ekoname 2,8 brutto.
Mhm.
Und möchte nicht, dass die Frau Werther trinkt.
Der Kunde hat verlangt...
Was?
Und möchte nicht, dass?
Dass wir die Zahn-Technikerin nicht höher stellen dürfen, wie seine festangestellten Mitarbeiter.
Sie aber gleichzeitig mit Mann und...
Ne, das ist natürlich dann blöd für die Vermittler, weil da bleibt weniger für die Vermittler übrig.
Auf der anderen Seite versteh ich's in gewisser Weise, weil für die schon bestehenden Mitarbeiter sieht das natürlich doof aus.
Ja?
Wenn dann eine neue kommt und die verdient viel, viel mehr als vielleicht die schon erfahreneren und dann sagen die natürlich, ey, das wollen wir auch haben.
Dass natürlich ein Drittel des Gehalts oder ein Viertel des Gehalts oder wie viel auch immer beim Vermittler liegen bleibt.
Ja, das ist denen natürlich dann nicht klar.
Die denken ja so nach dem Motto, oh, die wird viel krasser bezahlt.
Wahrscheinlich kommt am Ende sogar weniger bei der eigentlichen Fachkraft an, als bei denen, die hier schon eine Weile arbeiten.
Aber...
Die Forderung kann ich irgendwie noch nachvollziehen.
Und Katze und Hund nach Deutschland kommen möchte.
Deswegen waren wir uns da vorhin unschlüssig, ob wir das wirklich machen sollten.
Finde ich eine gute Sache, aber du kannst dir vielleicht deine Katze in Ruhe lassen.
Also wenn ich irgendwo anders hinziehen würde, was ich nicht vorhabe, ja, ich würde auch meine Katze mitnehmen.
Kann ich meine Katze nicht einfach da lassen?
Will ich auch gar nicht.
Dann würde ich lieber den neuen Job nicht anfangen, bevor ich meine Katze irgendwo zurücklasse.
Weil nachdem wir es durchkalkuliert haben, der Frau ziemlich wenig Geld zum Leben bleibt.
Okay.
Dann würde ich vielleicht meinen Kamil nochmal anrufen.
Ja.
Kamil.
Weil das ist ja wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr wenig Geld dann.
Das kann man fast nicht machen.
Wir können ja ganz offen sprechen.
Unsere Fachkräfte, die wir einstellen, verdienen durch doppelte Haushaltsführung, heißt steuerfreie Auslösen, mehr wie die Festangestellten bei der Firma.
In dem Fall ist es jetzt so, dass statt 2.700 netto, 2.700 brutto anstehen.
Dann rufst du jetzt den Herrn nochmal an, oder?
Mhm.
Okay.
Wir rufen jetzt an.
Ich sage aber auch gleich glück und klar, dass sie mit ihrem Mann kommen will und Haustieren.
Und das nur, wenn sie arbeitet.
Weil der Mann, denke ich mal, wird dann keine Arbeit haben.
Der chillt dann hier?
Oder wie?
Da müssen wir halt mit dem Kunden besprechen.
Also wenigstens für die ersten Monate vielleicht sogar die ganze Miete übernimmt.
Das wäre vielleicht nochmal ein Anhaltspunkt.
Und was macht der dann?
Der chillt da den ganzen Tag.
Na gut, der kümmert sich um die Haustiere.
4 in 27 Betreuung.
Ciao.
Und?
Passt.
Also ich habe jetzt hier schon 300 Euro Subvention eingerechnet.
Ich sage mal, die Unterkunft wird 900 Euro kosten.
Minus die 300, was wir schon extra bezahlen, sind dann noch 600, was übrig bleibt.
Dann bleiben ihr noch immer 1.250, 1.300 Euro zum Leben.
Das hättest du sehr gut gemacht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall.
Welche Klischees gibt es denn da in der Branche?
Also die ersten Worte, die immer folgen.
Die ersten Worte, die immer folgen, sind natürlich Sklavenhandel, was auch noch so ein Klischee ist.
Naja.
Ich sage mal so.
Sklavenhandel ist natürlich zu hart.
Aber auch wenn ich es jetzt ein paar Mal verteidigt habe im Video, aber ein gewisser Hauch des Unseriösen schwingt bei diesem ganzen Ding schon ein bisschen mit.
Ganz verhalten gesagt.
Das ist natürlich weit von Sklavenhandel entfernt.
Es ist auch weder illegal noch sonst was.
Ich sehe es auch voll rein, dass die Geld verdienen müssen.
So ein bisschen so verschachern ist das halt schon irgendwo.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, und das darf man auch nicht vergessen, es gibt Unternehmen, die suchen Leute und es gibt Leute, die suchen Jobs.
Also ist das ein vollkommen legitimes Geschäftsfeld.
Das ist halt das klassische Thema Ausbeutung.
Aber das haben wir jetzt mit dem Beispiel gerade auch widerlegt.
Es gibt immer noch viele schwarze Schafe in unserer Branche, das wissen wir.
Ja, das mit Sicherheit.
Auch teilweise Konkurrenz, die die Leute nicht so gut behandeln, wie sie es hätten sollen.
Übrigens, hat nichts mit dem Video zu tun.
Gleich gesagt.
Aber nur mal zum Thema Sklavenhandel.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass wenn jemand Besuch erhalten möchte aus Kolumbien.
Jetzt habe ich es.
Kolumbien.
Okay, ich muss euch das sagen.
Ich muss euch das anders, ich muss euch das anders erzählen.
Ein Kollege von mir hat eine Tochter in Kolumbien.
Der war früher in der Army, in den USA, in der Army.
Und ja gut, er ist halt ein bisschen rumgekommen und da hat eine Tochter in Kolumbien.
Und die Tochter aus Kolumbien wollte ihn besuchen vor, ich glaube letztes oder vorletztes Jahr zu Weihnachten.
Und die Tochter ist, glaube ich, erst 16, 15, 15, 16 so.
Und das war ein riesen Akt.
Das war wirklich ein unglaublicher Akt.
Und am Tag, wo die eigentlich in den Flieger steigen sollte, um nach Deutschland zu fliegen, haben sie ihr dort gesagt, sie darf nicht.
Und, what, warum, es war doch alles geklärt.
Ja.
Dann musste der Kollege nach Frankfurt fahren.
Das habe ich mitgekriegt, sonst wüsste ich das gar nicht.
Der musste nach Frankfurt fahren.
In die kolumbianische Botschaft.
Dort Fingerabdrücke abgeben.
Ausweis kontrollieren und Zeug ausfüllen, weil, und jetzt kommt es, weil Sklavenhandel.
Menschenhandel.
Anscheinend ist das in der Vergangenheit öfters vorgekommen, also das ist jetzt meine Interpretation des Ganzen, ja.
Wahrscheinlich ist es in der Vergangenheit öfters vorgekommen, dass mittelalte Männer aus Europa, Deutschland, sich minderjährige Mädels aus der Karibik bestellt haben.
Und die dann hier so, ja, man weiß ja nicht, was da gelaufen ist.
Und das soll dadurch verhindert werden.
Weil ganz im Ernst, wenn man sich das mal so überlegt, meine 15-jährige Tochter aus Kolumbien, von der nie jemand vorher was groß gehört hat, will mich besuchen kommen, klingt halt schon ein bisschen verdächtig, ja.
Natürlich, niemand was gehört, stimmt ja nicht.
Das ist ja offiziell anerkannt und alles.
Und da muss da wirklich Fingerabdrücke abgeben.
Ja.
Fingerabdrücke abgeben, Ausweis, dann musste die noch irgendwas ausfüllen und alles, bis das funktioniert hat.
Das war ein Riesenakt und die kam dann irgendwie auch erst irgendwie zwei Tage später abends an und er musste dann irgendwie noch 600 Kilometer mit dem Auto rumfahren.
Also ich glaube an dem Tag, ja, mehr oder weniger rechtzeitig, aber es war wirklich mega knapp.
Und da sieht man mal, da hängt schon einiges hinten dran, ja.
Ne, ich finde es auch nicht schlecht.
Es hat ja wohl Hand und Fuß, warum das gemacht wird, ja.
Es hat ja wohl Hand und Fuß, aber da sieht man mal, was es für Sachen gibt, woran man so pauschal gar nicht denkt.
Ist schon heftig, ne.
Gut, irgendwie in zwei Jahren oder so ist sie dann 18 und darf sie fliegen, wie sie will.
Ja und das Hauptproblem, warum das so ist, ist wahrscheinlich auch, weil ihr, also wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, weil sie nur einen gültigen kolumbianischen Pass hatte.
Und ihr amerikanischer Ausweis ist halt abgelaufen gewesen.
Also du hast ja automatisch, wenn dein Vater amerikanische Staatsbürgerschaftler ist, sind die Kinder ja auch automatisch, ja.
Irgendwie so läuft das.
Und ich glaube es gibt zwei Varianten, aber da habe ich echt wenig Plan von.
Ich glaube es gibt bei den Amis zwei Varianten.
Du kannst, entweder müssen die Eltern selbst, das ist seine Tochter, das ist glaube ich, da gibt es ja auch offizielle Dokumente dazu und sonst was.
Also der muss ja, der muss keinen Bluttest machen oder sowas.
Ne, ne.
Es muss halt alles aufgenommen werden, um halt die formalen Sachen einzuhalten.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Jetzt hast du mich abgelenkt.
Ja genau, es gibt ja glaube ich zwei Sachen, wie man amerikanischer Staatsbürger werden kann.
Und zwar das erste ist, die Eltern sind Kokona.
Und das zweite ist, du kommst auf amerikanischem Festland irgendwie zur Welt.
Das geht glaube ich auch.
Und ja, irgendwie, ich glaube das sind die zwei Möglichkeiten, wie man amerikanischer Staatsbürger werden kann.
Das habe ich mal in irgendeinem Beitrag gelesen.
Und es muss wohl, und das ist jetzt wirklich super krass, keine Ahnung, ja, aber das habe ich auch irgendwo mal gelesen.
Es muss wohl vor einer Weile einen Trend gegeben haben für Chinesen, dass die Schwanger, wie gesagt, keine Ahnung ob das stimmt.
Habe ich auch mal irgendwo gelesen.
Dass es einen Trend gab für bei Chinesen, etwas wohlhabenderen Chinesen, dass die Hochschwanger in Urlaub geflogen sind in die USA.
In der Hoffnung, das Kind kommt in dem Urlaub in den USA zur Welt.
Dass das quasi in den USA geboren ist und dann einen amerikanischen Pass bekommt.
Und man so irgendwie die Möglichkeit hat, da hinzukommen.
Wenn du High IQ, ja die haben ja ihr Green Card Programm.
Okay.
So und bei der war zumindest das Problem, dass ihr amerikanischer Pass abgelaufen war, sie einen kolumbianischen Pass hatten.
Deswegen gab es riesen, riesen hin und her.
Zumindest, wie ich da drauf gekommen bin, ist das, weil er gesagt hat im Video Sklaven- und Menschenhandel.
Also da gibt es durchaus mehr als man denkt, weil sonst gäbe es eben diese Gesetze nicht.
Aber hat nichts mit Personalvermittlung zu tun.
Ist mir nur bei der Gelegenheit eingefallen.
Ich glaube Leute, die sowas machen, haben auch nicht wirklich großartiges Interesse daran, weiter die chinesische Staatsbürgerschaft zu behalten.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich weg.
Gucken wir mal, fertig.
Die wird es aber immer geben.
Also ich würde mir halt einfach in dem Bereich wünschen, dass mehr Akzeptanz an den Tag gelegt wird.
Und es halt einfach unumgänglich ist, dass wir allein schon wegen dem demografischen Wandel keine Chance haben in Zukunft, ohne die Fachkräfte aus Osteuropa zu überleben in Deutschland.
Zu überleben ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen krass ausgedrückt.
Es gäbe ja auch noch die Möglichkeit, die Leute kriegen halt mal ein bisschen mehr Kinder und man macht das attraktiver.
Dass die Leute hier Kinder kriegen.
Gut, danke euch.
Merci.
Es gibt auch Wochen, wo es dann wirklich sehr anstrengend ist.
Wo man dann auch merkt, man läuft ein bisschen auf dem Zahnfleisch.
Wenn ich merke, ich brauche eine kurze Pause oder ich brauche ein bisschen Auszeit, dann arbeite ich auch weniger pro Woche.
Also das ist auch kein Thema.
Eigentlich war es ein kompletter...
Essen unterwegs.
Es sieht so aus, als haben die sich Pizza bestellt und zwei Bänke vor dem Büro stehen und gehen jetzt halt mal kurz in den Hof.
Fahreinstieg.
Ich kenne unseren Chef, den Philipp, schon relativ lange.
Dann haben wir uns in der damaligen Bar von meinem Vater getroffen, ein bisschen was getrunken
und dann sind wir halt auf den Konsens gekommen, dass wir künftig beruflich zusammenarbeiten wollen.
Wir sind ein sehr junges Team.
Wir verstehen uns alle auch super.
Die Schnittstellen untereinander können wir sehr gut klären, weil wir eben relativ flache Hierarchien haben.
Bei uns ist der Ablauf so, dass unsere Recruiter die Kandidaten anrufen, ob die Vorerfahrung passt,
ob die Dame oder der Herr Fragen hat zur Arbeit, zur Tätigkeit, zur Firma oder sonstiges.
Das prüfen wir dann immer noch zum Qualitätscall im Endeffekt.
Das machst du auch so ab und zu?
In Vertretung von ihm jetzt auch, ja.
Wir sind am Tag im Schnitt, ich denke, so 15 bis 20.
Bestes Regal.
Hallöchen.
Jawoll.
Geht's gut?
Gut.
Zu deiner Berufserfahrung.
Du warst über...
Das...
Ich glaube, das hat jeder schon mal gemacht.
Das ist so typisches, ich habe eigentlich gar keinen Bock, dich das zu fragen,
aber der Höflichkeits halber frage ich dich das jetzt mal.
Das hat jeder schon mal gemacht.
Hey, was geht und alles klar?
Und in Wirklichkeit denkst du dir, Alter, mir ist es scheißegal, wie es dir geht.
Ich will eigentlich nur fertig werden mit dem Call hier.
Habe ich selbst auch schon öfters bei mir gemerkt.
Geht's gut?
Gut.
Zu deiner Berufserfahrung.
Du warst überwiegend Grafiker, oder?
Druckgrafiker.
Du wirst überwiegend Heidelberg Speedmaster-Maschinen bedienen.
Heidelberg Speedmaster.
Sehr schön, super.
Hast du denn so zur Firma noch Fragen?
Haben die auch RGB?
...Arbeit oder so irgendwie zum Ablauf?
Es ist halt so, dass die Fachkräfte, die wir einstellen, halt überwiegend zum Arbeiten
nach Deutschland kommen.
Das heißt, die arbeiten auch lieber in Deutschland.
Ja, genau.
Das heißt, die arbeiten auch lieber in Deutschland?
Das heißt, die arbeiten auch lieber 10 Stunden mehr in der Woche oder im Monat.
Von meiner Seite aus ist es mehr als grünes Licht.
Ich würde vorschlagen Maschinenbediener 2500 Euro Netto, die ersten vier Wochen und
ab der fünften Woche würde ich 2650 machen.
Guten Tag dir.
Danke, ciao ciao.
Guter Mann. Da merkt man schon, dass er richtig gut war in dem Bereich, wo er tätig war.
Woran hat er das denn jetzt gemerkt?
Typischer Fall. Er ist in Polen Druckgrafiker gewesen oder ist es immer noch mit einer eigenen Firma seit zehn Jahren, seit zwölf Jahren.
Lohnt sich aber finanziell nicht so für ihn, wie wenn er nach Deutschland kommt und als Maschinenführer arbeitet.
Ich verdiene 10.500 Euro brutto pro Monat.
Ordentlich.
Netto circa knappe 6.000 Euro.
Mit Abzügen etc. kriege ich dann circa 5.500 Euro netto pro Monat.
Da geht was.
Abzüge sind einerseits meine...
Da kannst du dir mal überlegen, was da teilweise an Differenz rausgeholt wird, zwischen vermitteltem und dem, an die er vermittelt wird.
Übliche Altersvorsorge, dann habe ich noch einen Dienstrat, dass ich über den Arbeitgeber lese und eine Firmenwagenvereinbarung.
Dann nehmen wir uns dringend mal wieder in die Waschanlage.
Die Entfassung.
Die Entfassung zur Arbeit von der Wohnung ging auch problemlos mit dem E-Bike.
Das nutzen wir eigentlich in Richtung Sommer auch öfters mal.
Habe auch eigentlich irgendwie keinen Bezug zu Autos.
Deswegen ja, eigentlich viel Bequemlichkeit dabei.
Ich bin ein bisschen selbstkritisch.
Ich finde auch, dass das Gehalt, das ich im Monat bekomme...
Es ist mehr oder weniger das, was ich auch kriege mit Bonus.
Kommt recht gut hin.
Also wenn ein guter Bonus dabei ist.
...im Vergleich zu jemandem, der eine Wichtige hat.
Wie ein Arzt zum Beispiel.
Teilweise auch zu hoch ist.
Oder andererseits, dass die Ärzte eben eigentlich auch mehr verdienen sollten.
Kann ich nachvollziehen.
Oder so ein Sanitäter, Notfallsanitäter oder ähnliches.
Ich mag es halt sehr hell.
Ich finde es ein bisschen beruhigender soweit.
Wir haben einen schönen Balkon dann.
Schöne Lage.
Ja, wir haben uns schon ein bisschen was angeschaut, weil wir uns ein bisschen vergrößern wollen.
Weil wir auf Dauer auch vielleicht mal uns einen Hund anschaffen wollen.
Oder nochmal Nachwuchs sind.
In nächster Zeit vielleicht mal.
Aber...
Ach.
Das sollte man sich genau überlegen.
Nachdem wir bei Ihrem Elternhaus zu Hause einen relativ großen Bauplatz noch haben,
wird wahrscheinlich dann die Lösung eher dann selber bauen sein, anstatt nochmal ein Haus zu kaufen oder zu mieten oder ähnliches.
Tatsächlich ist es halt nicht so ein cooler Anreiz.
Hübsche Wohnung.
Sehr gutes Geld zu verdienen.
Weil eigentlich ein relativ großes Hobby von mir das Reisen ist.
Aber...
Also ich persönlich mag ja solche Deko-Dinger nicht, weil ich finde die stehen immer im Weg.
Aber insgesamt finde ich ist das sehr schick.
Ist das sehr schick?
Sehr stylisch irgendwie.
Sieht gemütlich aus.
Wahrscheinlich hat es die Frau eingerichtet.
Die hat da vielleicht ein Händchen.
Hör immer.
In der heutigen Zeit...
War vielleicht ja auch er.
Ich finde es aber echt...
Ist das ein Mikroskop da hinten, Leute?
Ist das ein Mikroskop?
Oder ist das eine Lampe, die aussieht wie ein Mikroskop?
Eine Espresso-Maschine.
Ich dachte das sieht aus wie ein Mikroskop, alter.
Ich meine, alternativ, bei mir, ohne Scheiß, wisst ihr, wie ich das machen würde, wenn die bei mir so einen Beitrag filmen würden?
Ich würde aufräumen, die schönste Ecke zeigen und den Rest der Wohnung, da würde das ganze Zeug stehen, was ich hier vorhin weggeräumt habe, dass es hier ordentlich aussieht.
So würde ich das machen.
Gutes Geld zu verdienen, weil eigentlich ein relativ großes Hobby von mir das Reisen ist.
Das heißt, da kann ich mir auch sehr viel dafür leisten.
Ich investiere, glaube ich, auch relativ viel Geld in Fußballspiele.
Das heißt, wir fliegen auch gerne mal über das Wochenende nach London und schauen uns da ein Spielchen an oder Ähnliches.
Also mein Job lohnt sich.
Wenn es die nächsten fünf Jahre so weiterläuft, wie jetzt, bin ich sehr glücklich darüber, würde ich sagen.
Und 15 Jahre?
Würde ich immer noch mitgehen.
Was und und was?
Würde ich sagen.
Und 15 Jahre?
Was und?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Was?
Was soll ich?
Verstehe ich das?
Und 15 Jahre?
Ach, 15 Jahre!
Würde ich immer noch mitgehen.
Ja.
Oh nein, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Also Bock, so einen Job zu machen, hätte ich nicht.
Aber ich sehe ein, dass es jemand geben muss, der das macht.
Nicht wie der AliExpress, oder?
Okay.
In letzter Zeit, wenn ich Video von Hardware-Deals empfohlen bekomme, dann ist es, wir haben eine CPU bei AliExpress gekauft.
Dieses Notebook bei AliExpress schockiert uns.
Eine Grafikkarte bei AliExpress.
Ein Komplett-PC bei AliExpress.
Zum Thema Born-User.
Echt, macht das Linus Tech Tips auch so?
Ich gucke wenig Linus Tech Tips.
Was ist denn eigentlich aus diesem ganzen Beef rausgekommen bei Linus Tech Tips?
Die hatten sich doch in den Haaren mit irgendeinem...
Anderen Technik-Channel, der gesagt hat, die Tests bei Linus Tech Tips würden sacken.
So, mal kurz, Kurzfassung des Ganzen.
Leute, bei mir an der Decke, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
An der Decke hängt irgendwas, könnte auch nur ein Fussel sein.
Ich glaube, es ist eine Motte.
Ups, jetzt habe ich das runtergeschmissen, na geil.
Ich glaube, es ist nur eine Motte.
Also, halb so wild.
Müsste ich jetzt eigentlich mal einsaugen oder platt machen, aber ich habe gerade nichts hier.
Ah.
Die ist nachher auch noch da.
Okay, da sind sie ja nochmal gut rausgekommen.
Ob das dann wirklich so ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber anscheinend haben sie die Leute beruhigt.
Na denn.
Okay, was können wir uns denn als nächstes sagen?
Zeige ich mal her, was haben wir denn hier?
Microsoft, ja, Maurice, Maurice guckt schon immer gern.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu Hause?
Passwort, Storage, Tierlist.
Das muss ich mir auch noch angucken.
Weil, irgendwie hat das eine mit dem anderen wenig zu tun.
YouTube können wir Zicht machen.
Guck mal hier, ich werde...
Ja, Passwortmanager, Store, Tierlist.
Ah, nee.
Chat-GPT, da habe ich jetzt echt keinen Nerv drauf.
Wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt hier.
Wir gucken jetzt das, was Maurice sagt zur Blizzard, Activision und Microsoft-Übernahme.
Die ist ja seit einer Woche oder zwei Wochen irgendwie durch.
Hast du zwei Katzen oder willst du dir eine zweite zulegen?
Das habe ich mir schon öfters überlegt.
Also aktuell habe ich eine.
Ich weiß auch, dass es prinzipiell besser ist, zwei zu haben.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob es bei Chico besser ist, zwei zu haben.
Weil Chico hat prinzipiell vor allem Schiss.
War bisher...
Ihr Leben lang auch alleine.
Also vermutlich zumindest.
Und sobald irgendwie nur was anderes in der Nähe ist, sitzt sie in der Ecke und faucht.
Also...
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt für Chico eine gute Idee ist.
Ansonsten hätte ich eigentlich auch ganz gern zwei.
Weil da können die miteinander ein bisschen Action machen.
Leute, ich muss mal ganz kurz pinkeln vorher.
Kurz.
Zack.
Peepo-Poo-Poo.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
So.
Wieder da.
Ich habe mir gerade noch mal den Arm eingecremt.
Alles klar, Leute.
Dann...
Gucken wir uns doch mal das Video an.
Spannend, was Maurice dazu sagt.
Also meine Meinung ist, Microsoft sind auch nicht bekannt so als die reinen Menschenfreunde.
Also, ob das wirklich besser wird...
Ich meine, bei Activision ist es schon sehr beschissen gewesen.
Bei Blizzard ging es die letzten Jahre auch ganz steil bergab.
Bis über Baldur's Gate 3.
Durch.
Nein, bin ich nicht.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit wenig, wenig gespielt.
Dritter Akt ist auch etwas, ja, pepeger noch.
Microsoft kauft endlich Activision Blizzard King.
Der wohl unbeliebteste Mann im Gaming ist damit bald bei Blizzard raus.
Ja, das stimmt.
Bobby ist weg.
Und wir alle fragen uns, wird jetzt endlich alles gut?
Vielleicht.
Also manches.
Nicht alles.
Vor allem nicht, wenn ihr Playstation-Spieler seid.
Und deswegen dachte ich mir, ich will in diesem Video mal alle Fragen,
beantworten, die euch auf der Seele brennen,
dazu, was dieser Deal jetzt...
Wobei ich nicht denke,
wobei ich echt nicht denke, dass Call of Duty und sowas Xbox-exklusiv wird,
weil es ja immer noch eine Abwägung ist.
Es ist eine Abwägung zwischen,
wie viel Kohle können wir auf der Playstation machen,
ob diese Exklusivitätsgeschichte mit der Playstation weitergeht.
Ah, da bin ich, da habe ich so meine Zweifel,
aber das gar nicht mehr dort rausbringen.
Das ist ja eine Abwägung zwischen,
wie viel Kohle bringt das auf der Playstation,
zu releasen versus, wie viel kann man anderweitig machen
und was Microsoft was bringt.
Da glaube ich, dass das Verhältnis aktuell noch nicht so ausschlaggebend ist.
Also ich denke nicht, dass das der Fall sein wird zur Zeit schon,
dass sie Playstation komplett außen vor lassen.
Aber ganz davon abgesehen ist mir das auch wurscht,
weil Call of Duty geht mir spätestens seit den ganzen
Modern Warfare Remastered Sachen,
also die Rebooted Sachen,
das finde ich so geil,
krass kreativ,
brankrott,
jetzt endgültig.
Ich werde mir das auch dieses Jahr nicht kaufen.
Und das hättest du schon nicht geholt.
Was das eigentlich für uns Gamer bedeutet.
Und wenn ich irgendwelche vergesse,
dann schreibt sie mir in die Kommentare
und dann hole ich das pflichtbewusst nach.
Anfangen möchte ich mit einer Frage,
die euch vielleicht gar nicht auf der Seele brennt,
weil man vielleicht gar nicht weiß,
dass man sie sich noch stellen muss.
Und zwar, ist der Deal denn jetzt wirklich final durch?
Es sieht so aus.
Microsoft hat ja sogar einen Trailer veröffentlicht,
dass das jetzt passiert.
Und ja,
das passiert jetzt.
Microsoft und Activision Blizzard King
machen das allerdings zu einem gewissen Grad
noch auf Verdacht.
Denn es gibt immer noch behördlichen Widerstand
gegen den Deal.
Kommt jetzt der Master Chief in Heroes of the Storm,
wobei Heroes of the Storm ist ja im Endeffekt
auf Live-Support.
Der ihn im Nachhinein
immer noch ungeschehen machen könnte,
was ein bürokratischer Halbtraum wäre,
wenn es passieren sollte.
Es gab zwei Behörden im Wesentlichen,
die sich gegen diesen Deal gestemmt haben,
weil sie der Meinung sind,
dass er den Wettbewerb im Videospielbereich
zu stark beeinträchtigt.
Und das war einmal in England
und einmal in den USA.
In England drehte sich das Argument
vor allem um Cloud Gaming
und dass Microsoft zusammen mit Activision Blizzard King
hier zu dominant werden könnte.
Dieses Argument hat viele ehrlich gesagt...
Cloud Gaming.
Was ist denn hier eigentlich mit...
Ja gut, ich weiß, die gibt es nicht mehr.
Aber da wurden vor ein paar Jahren
ja auch so getastet,
als bricht jetzt das neue Gaming-Zeitalter an.
Ich habe mir damals schon gedacht,
Leute, entspannt euch mal ein bisschen.
Überrascht, als es rauskam,
mich eingeschlossen,
Cloud Gaming ist aktuell kein riesiger Markt
und angesichts des kompletten Untergangs von Stadia
wirkte das Argument sogar dezent lächerlich.
Aber seitdem haben wir geleakte Dokumente
von Microsoft gesehen,
die zeigen, dass sie Cloud Gaming,
als eine der wichtigsten Zukunfts-Säulen
ihrer Gaming-Strategie sehen.
Und plötzlich wirkt das Ganze
längst nicht mehr so weit hergeholt.
Microsoft ist im Bereich Cloud
auch sehr stark aufgestellt.
Das hat man vielleicht gar nicht so auf dem Schirm,
wenn man vor allem die Gaming-News
und die Xbox-Sparte verfolgt.
Aber die ist tatsächlich ein Zwerg
innerhalb dieser Firma,
verglichen mit dem Server- und Cloud-Business,
zu dem unter anderem Azure gehört.
Microsoft ist hier ein Titan.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und deswegen...
Xbox ist wirklich ziemlich mini.
... gut positioniert, falls ein Titan...
Ich finde, das ist eine gute Grafik.
Und wisst ihr, was man daran auch dran sieht, ist,
dass Windows bei weitem nicht den Stellenwert hat,
wie das manche Leute sich denken.
Und Office, jetzt mal hier,
Office ist auch Cloud-Services.
Also im Prinzip sind 55% Cloud-Services
von Microsoft schon.
Bing, könnte man sagen,
ist auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein Cloud-Service.
Und dass LinkedIn zu Microsoft gehört,
wusste ich gar nicht.
Wusste dir das?
... deswegen gut positioniert,
falls das im Gaming künftig immer wichtiger werden sollte,
wie es einige prophezeien.
Allerdings hat die britische Behörde
ihren Einwand zurückgezogen,
nachdem Microsoft mit mehreren Lösungen
zu ihrer Zufriedenheit dafür gesorgt hat,
dass der Wettbewerb im Cloud-Gaming erhalten bleibt.
Und diese Lösungen sind dezent bizarr,
so von außen.
Die Cloud-Gaming-Gruppen, die wir hier haben,
die wir hier haben,
die Cloud-Gaming-Rechte für Activision-Blizzard-Spiele
gingen nämlich an Ubisoft ausgerechnet.
Hä? What?
Also an eine andere Konkurrenzfirma.
Das haben die wahrscheinlich nur gemacht,
dass das Gericht sagt,
ja, ist gut,
gehen wir uns nicht weiter auf den Keks.
... jetzt das Recht hat,
rein theoretisch Microsoft selbst zu verweigern,
diese Spiele auf ihren eigenen Cloud-Diensten anzubieten.
Was unwahrscheinlich wirkt,
aber was wir hier sehen,
was theoretisch ginge,
weil Ubisoft jetzt die Hoheit über diese Rechte hat.
Das betrifft aber interessanterweise nicht uns in Europa.
Im europäischen Raum gab es als Zugeständnis
an die Europäische Kommission einen anderen Deal,
der dafür gesorgt hat,
dass tatsächlich jeder Cloud-Anbieter
das Gratis-Recht bekommen soll,
für jeden Nutzer,
der ein Spiel in dieser Region besitzt,
es zu streamen.
Also da wurde wirklich die Cloud-Gaming-Dominanz,
die man da befürchtet hat,
massiv aufgeweicht.
Und das ist ja auch ein sehr wichtiger Punkt,
weil es ja auch ein sehr wichtiger Punkt ist,
um sicher zu gehen,
dass das in Ordnung geht.
Die amerikanische Behörde hat sich in ihrer Argumentation
deutlich mehr auf die Konkurrenz mit Sony konzentriert
und dass die Gefahr besteht,
dass Call of Duty nicht mehr auf der Playstation erscheint
und das den Markt.
Okay, das scheint für die Amis ganz furchtbar wichtig zu sein.
Dass man sich da auf einzelne Gaming-Sachen,
auf einzelne Marken stützt,
finde ich merkwürdig.
Zu sehr beeinträchtigt.
Diese Behörde hat sich da auf einzelne Marken gestützt.
Sie hat bislang ihre Prozesse verloren,
will aber diese Entscheidungen anfechten.
Das heißt, es könnte immer noch passieren,
dass sie noch Recht bekommt.
Allerdings halte ich es für sehr unwahrscheinlich,
weil sie hat diese Prozesse richtig krachend verloren.
Rechtliche Dokumente sind normalerweise nicht unterhaltsam.
Aber wie die Richterin hier
auf dem Experten der Behörde rumgehackt hat,
das muss man sich anschauen, um es zu glauben.
Das ist absurd.
Da wurde das auch gesagt.
Vielleicht haben sie den amerikanischen Christian Pfeiffer geschickt.
... vorgebracht, dass wenn Call of Duty nicht mehr auf der Playstation erscheint,
dass dann 20% aller Spieler sich stattdessen eine Xbox kaufen würden.
Also 20% aller Spieler, die an Call of Duty interessiert sind,
sich stattdessen eine Xbox kaufen würden, um es dort zu spielen.
Diese Zahl hat sich der Experte wohl einfach ausgedacht.
Und das hat die Richterin auch kritisiert in ihrem Statement.
Zu den Beweismaterialien, die er anführt,
er hat sie gefragt.
Welche Daten stecken dahinter?
Wer hat sie sich ausgedacht?
Professor Lee weiß es nicht.
Und was sagt Professor Lee zur Kritik an seinen Argumenten?
Nichts.
Was bei der Anhörung?
Wieder nichts.
Also, wenn die FTC-Behörde nicht deutlich überzeugender wird,
gehe ich erstmal davon aus, sie wird sich hier nicht mehr durchsetzen.
Was jetzt erstmal irgendwie alles witzig ist,
aber natürlich stellt sich die Frage für uns als Gamer,
ist es denn gut für uns, dass dieser Deal durchging?
Tja.
Dröseln wir das mal auf anhand der Frage, die da diskutiert wurde.
Heißt das jetzt mehr Exklusivspiele?
Bei Call of Duty müssen wir uns erstmal keine Sorgen machen.
Es gibt ein 10-Jahres-Abkommen mit Sony und mit Nintendo,
dass Call of Duty auf ihren Plattformen erhalten bleibt.
Aber...
Moment, es gibt...
Es gibt auf der Switch...
Es gab Modern Warfare auf der Switch?
Aber erstens nur 10 Jahre, das ist eine lange Zeit.
Moment, ernsthaft?
Ja.
Das war mir nicht klar, dass das auf der Switch ist.
Ist das auch irgendwie runterskaliert oder so?
Ach, Cloud Gaming über die Switch.
Das ist Cloud Gaming auf der Switch.
Ach so.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das gab es doch überhaupt nicht auf der Switch.
Cloud Gaming.
Zeit jetzt so gesehen, aber ist auch irgendwann vorbei.
Und zweitens auch nur Call of Duty.
Und Microsoft hat zuletzt mit Starfield und Redfall gezeigt,
dass sie durchaus gewillt sind, die Spiele aus ihren eigenen Studios,
selbst ganz große Blockbuster wie Starfield,
die wahrscheinlich auf der Playstation eine Menge Geld eingebracht hätten,
von der Playstation abzuziehen.
Und das, obwohl sie 2021 vor dem Bethesda-Kauf,
der ja auch durch diese gleichen Behörden musste,
noch argumentiert haben, wir haben keinen Anreiz,
ZeniMax-Spiele auf Konkurrenzkonsolen einzuschränken.
Inzwischen wissen wir, auch Elder Scrolls VI kommt nicht dazu.
Und Microsoft hat Bethesda sogar gezielt gekauft,
damit Sony diese Spiele nicht exklusiv bekommt.
Ich gehe also davon aus, wir werden mittel- bis langfristig
mehr Exclusives sehen, die nicht auf der Playstation erscheinen.
Und das wird...
Ey, solange die im Game Pass und für PC verfügbar sind, juckt mich das nicht.
Aber natürlich, für Playstation-Spieler schon problematisch.
Auch große Namen betreffen, wie eben zum Beispiel Elder Scrolls
oder vielleicht in der Zukunft auch Diablo und dergleichen.
Und Exclusives, muss man einfach so direkt sagen, sind immer blöd für Spieler.
Ich bin überhaupt kein Fan davon.
Lass die Leute da spielen, wo sie wollen.
Gerade das ist ja etwas, was sich Microsoft sogar offiziell auf die Flagge schreibt.
Und da muss der Fan deshalb sagen, ich mag Microsoft-Exclusives
lieber als Sony-Exclusives, weil sie immerhin direkt auf den PC kommen
und nicht erst Jahre später, weil Sony jetzt auch mal gemerkt hat,
dass PC-Gamer Bock auf geile Spiele haben und bereit sind, dafür Geld zu zahlen.
Ja.
Es gibt auch Positives, was die Verfügbarkeit von Spielen angeht.
Ich hätte ja echt gerne die ersten drei Uncharted-Games auf dem PC.
Die würde ich gerne mal wieder spielen.
Mit dem Emulator geht es teilweise, aber Uncharted ist eines der,
sagen wir mal, schwierigsten Spiele zu emulieren.
...Spiele jetzt in den Game Pass kommen.
Erst 2024 zwar, aber trotzdem.
Und auch sonst zu mehr Anbietern, wie zum Beispiel bizarrerweise Ubisoft.
Das bringt uns zur nächsten Frage.
Jetzt, wo Microsoft Activision Blizzard King gekauft hat,
werden die Spiele denn besser dadurch?
Der CEO Bobby Kotick soll schon Ende 2023 gehen.
Wir erinnern uns, das ist der Mann...
Und wie viel Money kriegt er als Abfindung?
...allen Spaß aus der Videospiel-Entwicklung nehmen wollte
und sich ganz gut Mühe gegeben hat, dieses Ziel zu erreichen.
Unter Kotick ist vor allem Blizzard gieriger und verlogener geworden.
Das stimmt.
Es ist eine Firma, die ihre Spiele aggressiver monetarisiert,
siehe Diablo Immortal,
und keine Scheu hat, ihren Kunden rundheraus...
Wisst ihr, was ich witzig finde?
Ich habe damals ein Video gemacht zu diesem Activision-Blizzard-Zusammenschluss.
Und da haben mich die Leute noch...
Und ich habe damals auch, ich weiß nicht mehr was genau,
aber damals auch sinngemäß im Video gesagt,
ich habe echt meine Bedenken, was das managementtechnisch,
was das für einen Einfluss haben wird auf Blizzard-Qualität
und auf Blizzard-Spiele.
Da haben die Leute gesagt,
Max, erzähl keinen Mist,
es wäre jetzt ja nicht so,
dass irgendwie heute Blizzard bei Activision angestellt ist
und da passiert nichts,
das ist rein BWL-Gedöns
und die haben ja gar nichts miteinander zu tun.
Ich habe mir damals schon gedacht,
naja, also das wächst immer weiter zusammen,
da gibt es ein Management oben drüber,
gemeinsame Strategie.
Aber wollten mir die Leute damals erzählen,
kompletter Blödsinn.
Und man hat jetzt gesehen,
ein ganz so kompletter Blödsinn war es dann doch nicht.
...siehe Warcraft 3 Reforged.
Und dann auch überhaupt...
Deforged, ja.
...nicht bestrebt ist,
solche Fehltritte wieder gut zu machen.
Mitarbeiter werden derweil so schlecht behandelt,
dass viele führende Blizzard-Köpfe abgehauen sind
und die Verbliebenen es immer schwerer haben,
unter diesen Bedingungen gute Spiele zu machen.
Es ist ziemlich bemerkenswert,
wie viele Mitarbeiter sich öffentlich auf Twitter
über die Unternehmenskultur
und auch konkret über Bobby Kotick
ihren Oberboss auskotzen.
Das muss ja ziemlich weit gehen,
dass man sich das überhaupt traut
und dass man das Gefühl hat,
man hat keine andere Wahl als das.
Ja.
Vor allem musst du damit rechnen,
dass der dich dann morgen dafür rausschmeißt
und trotzdem ist den Leuten egal.
Also da muss der Frust schon echt tief sitzen.
Die Firma hat sogar öffentlich in Investorenberichten zugegeben,
sie hat einen schlechten Ruf als Arbeitsplatz
und hat daher Probleme,
gute Leute zu finden und zu halten,
was notwendig ist,
um mit der Konkurrenz Schritt zu machen.
Die haben ja auch alles dafür getan,
einen schlechten Ruf zu haben.
Nicht nur was die Games angeht,
wir erinnern uns dran,
was bei Blizzard die letzten Jahre über noch gelaufen ist.
Ich sag nur McCree.
Es ist auch naiv zu glauben,
dass sowas nur an einem Mann hängt
und dass das jetzt alles magisch wieder gut wird,
wenn der...
Aber das hat, ohne Scheiß,
das hat trotzdem Auswirkungen,
je nachdem wie die Weichen gestellt werden
und was für eine Marschrichtung vom oberen Management da kommt.
Das hat enorm viel Einfluss drauf.
Natürlich wird es nicht von heute auf morgen,
nur weil die gekauft werden,
jetzt alles anders werden.
Das ist schon klar.
Da werden auch einige Leute ausgetauscht werden müssen,
sodass die neue Vision,
wenn es denn eine neue gibt,
da ordentlich vertreten wird.
Und ob die dann besser ist für uns als Spieler,
als die bisherige,
das muss ich noch zeigen.
Oder vielleicht auch ein paar seiner Mitbosse gehen.
Unter anderem natürlich,
weil auch viel Schaden einfach schon angerichtet ist.
Es sind ja schon viele gute Leute gegangen,
auch wenn manche jetzt wieder zurückkommen,
wie Chris Madsen zum Beispiel.
Aber...
Ach!
Ach, der ist wieder da?
Der ist doch quasi in Rente quasi gegangen
vor ein paar Jahren.
Solche Probleme sind ja etwas tiefer verwurzelt
in einer Firmenkultur.
Auch wenn man immer wieder gesehen hat,
es gibt bei...
Das ist unter anderem der,
der auch viele,
der, wenn ihr in Warcraft 3 gespielt habt,
viele der Sounds damals noch selbst eingesprochen hat.
Der ist ja schon ewig dabei.
Zwischen Blizzard auch Leute,
die da nicht ankämpfen.
Oder war ewig dabei.
Also, wer weiß.
Und man muss auch dazu sagen,
auch Microsoft ist kein perfekter Arbeitgeber.
Auch die haben sich eingereiht in die Riege der Arbeitgeber,
die gerade massiv Stellen abbauen.
Sie haben 2023 im Januar 10.000 Leute gefeuert.
Aber sie könnten trotzdem Besserung erwirken.
Denn es gibt auch Anzeichen,
dass es unter Microsoft vielleicht
ein wenig Licht am Ende des Tunnels geben könnte.
Zum Beispiel hat sich Microsoft festgelegt,
nicht gegen Gewerkschaften bei Activision Blizzard King vorzugehen.
Wohingegen Bobby Kotick der Meinung war,
es gab bei der Firma sowieso nie Probleme mit der Arbeitskultur.
Und das alles ist nur eine Schmutzkampagne
von einer aggressiven Arbeiterbewegung,
die Firma zu destabilisieren.
Es sprechen...
Wisst ihr, was an diesen Meldungen,
so das, ähm...
Wie heißt das, ähm...
Ja, das Werkwürdige ist,
das ist durchaus möglich,
dass der das wirklich denkt.
Es gibt ja immer so das Ding,
so okay, wir machen das jetzt,
weil es eine offizielle Pressemeldung ist.
Es ist durchaus möglich,
dass der das wirklich denkt.
Tiefen Arbeiterbewegungen...
Das Bizarre, würde Maurice sagen, ja.
Dass das durchaus sein könnte,
dass der das wirklich denkt.
...Firma zu destabilisieren.
Es sprechen durchaus Sachen für Microsoft als Arbeitgeber.
Ich habe mit mehreren Entwicklern im Laufe der Jahre geredet,
die sehr glücklich dort waren und darüber waren,
Teil von Microsoft zu sein.
Zum Beispiel Brian Fargo,
der sich eigentlich schon zur Ruhe setzen wollte
und dann meinte,
der Microsoft-Kauf war der Grund,
warum er weiter Spiele machen will.
Unter anderem, weil er unter deren Schirmherrschaft
und, ganz klar direkt gesagt,
mit deren Geld Wasteland 3
zu einem noch viel cooleren Spiel machen konnte.
Und Wasteland 3 war eigentlich,
Wasteland 3 war ein verdammt gutes Rollenspiel.
Außerdem erlaubt Microsoft
sehr kreative, experimentelle Spiele,
wie zum Beispiel Pentiment,
wo man sich nicht vorstellen kann,
dass ein Schriftrollenspiel im Mittelalter
in einer bayerischen Stadt,
dass das unter Activision Blizzard
möglich gewesen wäre.
Wo bringt das denn die finanziellen Sachen ein,
die wir brauchen?
Wo sind die Mikrotransaktionen?
Also, es besteht zumindest Hoffnung,
dass unter Microsoft
die Dinge ein wenig nach oben gehen,
wieder für Activision Blizzard
und wie gesagt, vor allem für Blizzard.
Also, kriegen wir unter Microsoft
wieder Blizzard-Spiele?
Wisst ihr, wie interessant?
Das ist das allerallererste World,
oder das ist das World of Warcraft
Original Classic Intro Cinematic.
Wie gut das damals schon ausgesehen hat, ne?
Wie früher.
Also, so Renderfilme,
das konnten die schon immer.
Microsoft hat ja auch gezeigt,
dass sie Bock drauf haben
und sich darauf verstehen,
alte Klassiker,
sogar ganz konkret im Old-School-RTS-Bereich,
wieder aufleben zu lassen.
Age of Empires 2 floriert unter der Schirmherrschaft
von Microsoft wie lange davor nicht mehr
und wie wir es uns für all die anderen
großen Strategie-Franchises dieser Zeit
nur wünschen können.
Und hey, in diesem Trailer,
den sie gezeigt haben,
ist auch StarCraft drin,
der Trailer zu dieser Firmenzusammenkunft.
Allerdings sprechen auch hier wieder Punkte dagegen.
Age of Empires 4 war allem Anschein nach
nicht ganz der Erfolg,
den sich Microsoft vermutlich erhofft hat,
würde ich zumindest vermuten.
Also, Age of Empires 4,
ich habe es nicht gespielt,
also nicht aktiv gespielt,
ich habe aber auf Twitch öfters mal geguckt.
Das hatte einen immensen Hype ursprünglich,
gerade auch, was die E-Sport-Szene angibt.
Da gab es wirklich an jeder Ecke Turniere und Streamer
und sonst was.
Ich gucke ja ganz gerne bei Krabi öfters so,
wenn es um Strategiespiele geht.
Und die haben wohl das gleiche Problem
wie viele andere Entwickler gehabt.
Das Spiel war draußen
und dann hat sich halt die ganzen Probleme rausgestellt,
die es gab, Multiplayer-technisch.
Und es hat eeeewig gedauert,
bis irgendwelche Sachen balanced wurden,
gepatcht wurden,
auch einfach kaputte Sachen angepasst wurden.
Ewig.
Und mittlerweile sind die meisten Leute weg davon.
Und ich glaube, Turniere gibt es auch immer weniger.
Und ja, ob es überhaupt noch Orgas gibt,
die die Age of Empires 4-Spieler,
glaube ich, weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist echt ein bisschen zu lange im Sande verlaufen
nach Release.
Es wird weiterentwickelt und es ist inzwischen,
es war immer schon ein tolles Spiel.
Es hatte zu Release leider einige Probleme,
die zu spät angegangen wurden.
Und es hat enttäuscht auf der Singleplayer-Kampagnenfront.
Aber es ist ein cooles RTS.
Und es ist schade,
dass es dann ein wenig untergegangen ist
nach einem starken Start.
Und ich könnte mir halt vorstellen,
dass das bei Microsoft,
sage ich mal,
die Lust auf Oldschool-RTS-Markenrevivals
wieder ein wenig abkühlen hat lassen.
Wir haben auch schon lange nichts mehr
von Age of Mythology Retold gehört,
was ich unbedingt haben will.
Microsoft, wann?
Das war ehrlich gesagt nicht meins.
Aber ja, also es ist nicht garantiert,
dass Microsoft das Age-2-Schema
und das auf Blizzard-RTS-Franchises anwenden wird
und die dann fortführen wird.
Aber es ist zumindest wahrscheinlicher,
als es davor war.
Weil davor haben wir ja gemerkt,
haben sie offensichtlich überhaupt keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Siehe Warcraft 3 Reforged.
Es ist zumindest nicht schlimmer geworden.
Es gibt mehr Hoffnung als vorher.
Das ist doch heutzutage auch schon was,
worüber man sich freuen muss.
Deswegen das Fazit.
Also was sich an Warcraft 3 reforged von...
Also wenn man sich jetzt Videos anguckt,
die richtig, richtig gute...
Warcraft 3-Spieler drüber gemacht haben,
eines der Hauptkritikpunkte ist,
dass man keine Übersicht mehr hat.
Dass die Silhouette der Units nicht richtig passt.
Dass die ganze...
Wie soll man sagen?
Die ganze Crispness,
sodass man immer jederzeit erkennt,
was wie wo passiert,
auch im Getümmel,
dass das mit den reforged Models
und der reforged Grafik nicht gegeben ist.
Ne, aber ganz klar,
es gibt noch viele andere Sachen,
die versprochen wurden und weggelassen wurden.
Deswegen spielt auch kaum einer
der ehemaligen Warcraft 3 Pros,
weiß ich, ob es heute noch...
Ja doch, gibt es in China,
gibt es immer noch welche.
Also keiner eigentlich mit reforged Grafiks.
Activision Blizzard King Deal.
Gut fürs Gaming.
Ich persönlich freue mich darüber.
Sage ich so direkt.
Einfach nur wegen Blizzard.
Es ist meiner Meinung nach die beste Chance,
die wir haben,
dass sich bei Blizzard was bessert.
Die Chance ist allemal höher.
Die Chance ist allemal höher,
als wenn der Deal nicht durchgegangen wäre
und die Firma unter Kotick verblieben wäre.
Das klingt sinnvoll, was er sagt.
Nein, Microsoft ist keineswegs...
Das...
Würde ich auch so unterschreiben.
Da besteht zumindest jetzt die Chance,
dass sich da was tut.
...unfehlbar.
Gerade neulich haben sie mit Redfall
ordentlich daneben gelangt.
Aber sie haben auch viel Gutes gemacht.
Es gibt hier allerdings einen breiteren Punkt,
der noch zu bedenken ist
und der mir Sorgen macht.
Wie gesagt,
diesen konkreten Deal finde ich aus purem Eigennutz.
Okay, jetzt kommt,
er findet es nicht gut,
dass so viel zentriert ist bei vielen großen Unternehmen.
Ich glaube, dass das jetzt kommt.
Dass es zu wenige nur noch gibt.
Weil ich ein besseres Blizzard will?
Gut.
Er ist aber auch ein weiterer Schritt im Trend
der stetigen Konsolidierung im Game.
Ja, das dachte ich mir, dass das jetzt kommt.
Was ich damit meine ist,
dass sich Gaming unter weniger und weniger
immer größeren Firmen zusammenfindet.
Und wenn diese Firmen mal Probleme haben
oder sich entscheiden, ihre Business-Strategie
jetzt ein wenig mehr auf rücksichtloses Geld machen zu trimmen,
dann leiden Spieler wie Entwickler darunter.
Wir sehen das gerade bei der Embracer Group,
zu denen auch THQ Nordic gehört,
bei denen ein 2-Milliarden-Deal
mit einer saudi-arabischen Firma geplatzt ist.
Und jetzt geht der Kahlschlag durch all deren Studios.
Und es werden bergeweise Entwickler gefeuert,
die absolut nichts dafür können,
dass der Chef ihres Chefs ihres Chefs
auf einen Deal spekuliert hat,
der am Ende nicht geklappt hat.
Das, ne, soll...
Solche Dinge können immer wieder passieren.
Und das sehe ich mit Sorge.
Siehe auch, wie gesagt, andere große Firmen wie Tencent,
wie natürlich auch Sony.
Das Gaming geht immer mehr in diese Richtung
und das kann nicht nur positive Effekte
für den Endkunden haben.
Am Ende ist auch Microsoft eine Firma im Konkurrenzkampf.
Sie sind nicht die Guten, die jetzt das böse Sony machen.
Das ist das, was ich am Anfang auch gemeint hab.
Das sind ja nicht alles Menschenfreunde jetzt über Nacht
bei Microsoft so, oh, jetzt wird alles gut.
Aber die Chance darauf, dass sich da bei Blizzard was ändert,
das finde ich, ist schon ein guter Punkt.
...liegt haben, um einen Deal aus purer Selbstlosigkeit
zum Wohle der Spieler durchzubringen.
Man sollte an dieser Stelle auch erwähnen,
dass zu Activision Blizzard ja auch noch King gehört.
Die Macher von Candy Crush.
Und einer der erfolgreichsten Mobile-Spielentwickler der Welt.
der welt wir core gamer haben das vielleicht gar nicht so auf dem schirm wenn wir über diese firma
reden weil es uns halt mehr um blizzard oder call of duty je nach spielgeschmack geht aber king ist
größer als blizzard und dürfte für microsoft sogar einer der wichtigsten strategischen gründe für
diesen kauf gewesen sein denn damit haben sie plötzlich ein enorm mächtiges standbein im
grässlichen mehr als eins sogar denn activision und blizzard haben sich ja ebenfalls mehr und
mehr auf diesen markt konzentriert in den letzten jahren ja leute habt ihr keine phones ja und ja
wir freuen uns ja immer wenn mehr firmen mehr profite mit mobile spielchen erzielen nicht wahr
und auch das ist eine konsequenz dieses deals aber es könnte
doch einiges gutes daraus erwachsen in der bestmöglichen zeit die gute diapo möglichsten
zeitlinie wäre bobby kotick jetzt von activision blizzard weg und wäre der neue ceo von playstation
geworden der da ist ja neulich ein wechsel stattgefunden aber zum glück leben wir leben
immerhin schon mal nicht in dieser schlechtmöglichsten zeitlinie vielleicht leben wir
also in einer in der in der da was was gutes draus erwächst also ich würde es nicht wundern wenn
bobby in irgendeiner position demnächst wieder auf ploppt
dieser geschichte ich werde erfolgreich war diablo immortal eigentlich also allem dem was
ich mitbekommen habe wohl enorm erfolgreich im auge behalten mit einem gespannten und
einem anfang schon auch ich denke es läuft immer noch nicht freuen wenn ihr mir vielleicht auch
auf twitch folgt twitch maurice weber dort werde ich auch live weiterhin über alle entwicklungen
berichten und das geht da manchmal noch etwas flotter als hier auf youtube wo man sich natürlich
ein wenig zeit nehmen will ein video mit substanz zurechtzulegen zu diesen themen ich hoffe das ist
gelungen ich hoffe das ist gut euch moris moris seine videos kamen sich immer gut geben immer
hyper das game war trash ja was haben wir sonst noch passt das muss ich mir jetzt angucken ich
weiß ich weiß nicht was das video mir sagen soll aber ich finde die sachen haben alle nix
großartig miteinander zu tun also in unterschiedliche sachen die man entweder zusammen oder exklusiv
verwenden kann weil hashing ist keine encryption und mal gucken vielleicht vielleicht taugt das video auch nix dann machen wir auch
aber kann ich auch meinen senf zu geben hast du das hier gesehen wie wenn es klingt wie diese wie
die android app mit der man früher youtube als alternativ klein gucken konnte thoughtAdmin verband
am bahn am arm richtig machen nun las heute nicht heute gibt es keine nudel mit lachs ich könnte mal
raten was meint ihr wenn es heute keine luk nudel mit lachs gibt heute gibt es keine nudel mit lachs
Was gibt's dann?
Gibt ja nicht so viele Möglichkeiten, ne?
Bolognese, richtig.
Nudeln mit Tomatensoße, Nackfleisch, korrekt.
So sieht's aus.
Ich seh schon, ihr wisst Bescheid, was es bei mir samstags zu essen gibt.
So, Passwords, zeigt mir ja, Storing.
Okay.
Ja, Plaintext, Passwörter in Plaintext storen ist immer highly pippiger.
Laut genug.
Okay, das Wörste ist wahrscheinlich Plaintext.
Ist die Laude.
In der Regel für, sagen wir mal, so Debug- und Testing-Sachen kann man das mal machen,
wenn man genau wissen will, was passiert, aber es sollte nie in einem fertigen Bild landen
und schon gar nicht in irgendeiner Production-Database sonst wie was im Klartext.
Ja, das ist eine schlechte Idee.
Hacker.
Security is all about multiple lines of defense
and storing passwords in Plaintext is not a defense.
If your database is breached, you're done
and database breaches happen quite often.
That's why this is f-ed here.
But how can we do better?
If you watched my encryption video,
you might think that we should encrypt these passwords.
That's definitely an improvement,
because if they break into your database, they get gibberish
instead of useful information.
Macht man aber in der Regel nicht so.
Aber...
If they do get access to the key,
then they can decrypt all the passwords.
And you're unfortunately right back to f-ed here.
It's definitely nicer that the passwords aren't just sitting out there in the open.
Am besten ist, wenn die Passwörter
überhaupt nicht
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
in der Datenbank stehen.
So machst du es eigentlich auch.
Also wenn es ordentlich gemacht ist,
wirst du keine Passwörter sowohl Plaintext als auch Encrypted in der Datenbank finden.
Oder überhaupt nicht auf Serverseite.
Ah.
Das Passwort verlässt am besten nie den Client.
Beziehungsweise nicht übertragen.
Einfach keine Passwörter nutzen.
Fife hat ja...
...access to your database already,
it may not be much more effort for them to steal the decryption key too
from an adjacent server or config file.
Also storing passwords in a way that makes it possible to retrieve the password
increases the risk of an inside job,
where an employee with privileged access to the key
decrypts people's passwords.
for nefarious purposes.
The extra protection certainly helps,
but this is D-tier.
How do we get to C?
The key insight is that we only need to know
when the user types in the same password
as when they signed up.
We don't actually need to know the password itself.
You might think the two are one and the same,
but they actually aren't.
It's possible to take a password and generate a fingerprint from it,
which will let us know if we encounter
the same password in the future,
but still be unable to recover the password
directly from the fingerprint.
This is a technique known as
hashing.
So, and now I have a question for you.
So, we can now, we're going to hash something now, yeah?
We're going to hash 123456, best password.
We're going to hash once as MD5
and once as SHA-256, uh, yeah.
So.
I'm going to notice something right now.
Let's take MD5, just because it's shorter, okay?
123456 as MD5.
And now let's do it, uh, 123457.
What's the difference between these two hashes?
Or what's the name of this stupid question?
So if you, you see the input,
the input has only changed here in one sign.
Same length, right?
That's one thing, yeah.
But, and that's very important for a good hash function,
the output also sees small changes in the input,
completely different.
That's the, that's the actual, that's the actual point.
So you're not supposed to be able to draw any conclusions
from the input to the output.
If, for example,
only a little bit here has changed,
if the input changes a little,
then there must be some kind of connection
between the two inputs.
That means, with a good hash function,
no matter how small the change is,
the input, the output is always completely,
let's say, different randomly.
So.
Jetzt ist aber natürlich auch so ein Ding, was man sich überlegen kann, wenn man sich hier jetzt mal das Passwort anguckt, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, wie lang kann der, also ihr seht, das ist immer gleich lang, der Hash hier.
Wir nehmen mal, wie gesagt, MD5, äh, was mach ich denn hier, 2, 3, ja, müssen wir noch, müssen wir noch das N, 32, 32, so, aber ist letztendlich auch wurscht. Ihr seht, der Output ist immer gleich lang. So, und jetzt überlegt mal, Chat, wie lang kann der Input sein? Wie groß kann der Input werden? Also Output wissen wir, der Output ist immer gleich lang, egal was man reinsteckt.
Der Input kann, naja, sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal, unendlich, in Anführungszeichen.
Weil, in irgendeiner Art und Weise ist es dann doch durch, durch, durch RAM und alles irgendwie beschränkt, aber sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal, nahezu, nahezu unbegrenzt, okay? Also, ich dürfte aber jetzt schon auffallen, wenn ich das hier reinstecke, ja, das ist länger als der Output. Das heißt im Endeffekt, der Output ist immer gleich lang, aber egal, wie der Input variiert, der Output ist immer gleich lang.
Das heißt im Umkehrschluss jetzt auch,
Hier hat man ja eine begrenzte Anzahl an Zeichen, um den Hashtag zu stellen.
Jetzt habe ich nochmal eine Frage an euch, Chat.
Ist es denn möglich, dass ich mit unterschiedlichem Input, mit zwei unterschiedlichen Inputs den gleichen Output bekomme?
Ja, ist möglich, ne?
Ist ja im Prinzip auch, ist ja im Prinzip auch irgendwie logisch. Das ist bei allen Hashes so.
Ne, ne, das ist nicht.
Das ist nicht nur bei MD5, das ist bei allen Hashes so.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist, das ist bei Chart 256 ganz genauso.
Bei Chart, bei Chart 256, ähm, ist es, ist es ein bisschen unwahrscheinlicher, ein bisschen unwahrscheinlicher ist gut.
Sagen wir mal so, ähm, Teil, Teilchen im Universum seit 14 Milliarden Jahren unwahrscheinlicher, also ich sehe viel unwahrscheinlicher, aber es ist etwas unwahrscheinlicher als bei MD5.
Aber nachdem du ja immer einen, sagen wir mal, nahezu unbegrenzt, äh,
äh, begrenzten Zeichenvorrat als Input benutzen kannst und das zusammenfassen musst, was quasi durch den Fleischwolf drehen muss, in was, was immer fixt, gleich lang ist,
kann es bei allen Hashing-Varianten Kollisionen geben.
Und jetzt kommt die Preisfrage.
Wie viel mögliche, also gehen wir mal von aus, du kannst unendlich viel Input reinpacken.
Wie viele Kollisionen kann es denn geben?
Und da müssen wir jetzt wirklich mal, müssen wir mal den Florian anhauen, ob das stimmt.
Was?
Ich würde auch sagen, es kann, es gibt potenziell bei jedem Hashing-Algorithmus unendlich viele Kollisionen.
Das Gute ist, dass es zwar theoretisch unendlich viele gibt, aber es enorm unwahrscheinlich ist, eine zu finden.
Das klingt jetzt erstmal widersprüchlich, ja.
Es gibt unendlich viele Kollisionen, theoretisch mögliche Kollisionen, aber trotzdem ist, glaube ich, für, für Schad 256 noch keine einzige
Kollision bekannt.
Ich glaube, es gibt für Schad 256 noch nicht eine einzige Kollision, die bisher gefunden wurde.
Also man sieht, auch wenn es theoretisch unendlich viele gibt, praktisch gesehen ist es doch sehr unwahrscheinlich, eine zu finden.
So, so viel so mal als, als kurzer, kurzer Exkurs dazu, ja.
Leitet sich das Soll vom ursprünglichen Plaintext-Input ab?
Nein.
Naja, je nachdem, wie man es nimmt.
Der, der Soll ist nicht Bestandteil hiervon.
Von deinem, von deinem Passwort, aber der Soll ist im, kommt im Plaintext mit dabei.
Ja, unendlich Inputs ist aufgrund von RAM und so, das habe ich ja gesagt, ist eigentlich gar nicht, gar nicht möglich.
Aber rechnen wir, also gehen wir mal theoretisch davon aus.
Du musst aber beim Soll natürlich den, das Plaintext-Passwort und dein Plaintext-Sold zusammen in die Hash-Funktion stecken.
Ja, aber das kommt wahrscheinlich jetzt gleich.
Gibt es bekannte Kollisionen für MD5?
Ja, da gibt es fünfte.
Da gibt es einige, ja.
Ja, das ist schon, ja.
Da gibt, da gibt es tatsächlich ein paar.
Ja, bekannte Kollisionen bei MD5, aber das meiste ist ein bisschen suboptimal, um es auf dem, um es auf dem Terminal zu zeigen, weil viele der Kollisionen sind entweder sehr lang oder halt, ja, nicht unbedingt gerade gut in ASCII darstellbar oder in, in, in Zeichen darstellbar.
Das sind dann irgendwelche Random-Hacks-Dinger, zweifelhaft.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es, dass es MD5-Kollisionen gibt, wo die gut lesbar sind.
Ja, dass man jetzt sagen würde, hallo, Chat und blub123 entspricht dem gleich.
Genau, sowas hier in der Richtung kennt man als Kollision.
Das ist halt, naja, ne, ein bisschen unhandlich.
Aber MD5 gibt es bekannte Kollisionen.
Ich glaube für, für Schad-206, Schad-206.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es überhaupt für Schad.
Ja, überhaupt was gibt.
Okay.
Für.
Okay, für die, für die alte, aber ich glaube für da gibt es, da gibt es noch keine.
Es ist aber halt auch enorm, es ist auch wirklich enorm unwahrscheinlich.
Es sei denn, und das darf man ja nie außer Acht lassen, es sei denn, jemand findet Schwächen im Hashing-Algorithmus.
Er findet beispielsweise doch Zusammenhänge zwischen Input und dem, was rauskommt.
Dann ist das was anderes.
Aber wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, dass der Hashing-Algorithmus selbst das macht, was er machen soll.
How to get arrested in 30 minutes, oder, MonkaTOS-Video, man weiß ja nie hier wie, bestimmt nur Cheatbait, Cheatbait-Titel.
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen?
Ja, aber wenn man davon ausgeht, dass das funktioniert, ist es doch sehr, sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass da eine gefunden wird.
Okay.
Ich kann euch nicht sagen, wie unwahrscheinlich.
Aber wir reden hier nicht in unwahrscheinlich, wie im Fahrstuhl abzustürzen, sondern wir reden hier von unwahrscheinlich, ähm, in Größenordnung, wo mir gar kein Beispiel für einfällt.
Ja, das ist auch noch ein Punkt, das ist ein bisschen wie, finde in der Klasse Leute, die zu deinem Geburtstag auch Geburtstag haben, versus finde zwei Leute in der Klasse, die zum gleichen Zeitpunkt Geburtstag haben.
Ja, das ist natürlich nochmal was anderes.
Das ist theoretisch einfacher, quasi, ähm.
Ja, finde zwei Hashes, die den gemeinsamen Input, die den gemeinsamen Hash ergeben, oder finde einen weiteren Input zu meinem vorgegebenen Input, der den gleichen Hash ergibt.
Ja, das ist noch mal was ganz anderes.
Also mir fällt wirklich keine Unwahrscheinlichkeitsvergleich ein, ähm, wie unwahrscheinlich das ist.
Also ich weiß es jetzt nicht in Zahlen, aber eine Kollision in Chart 256 zu finden, ist wahrscheinlich so unwahrscheinlich, wie...
Ähm, ja, keine Ahnung, dass in den letzten 14 Milliarden Jahren es euch schon ein anderes Mal gab auf irgendeinem anderen Planet, so nach dem Motto, es ist enorm unwahrscheinlich.
Nein, das ist deutlich, das ist DEUTLICH höher, die Chance, das auf den Kopf zu bekommen, als eine Chart-265-Kollision zu finden.
Also, weiter, weiter Video gucken.
Ah, ne, ist immer hier.
Ups, da.
Das ist ja das, was ich auch gerade gezeigt habe.
Technik, die als Hashing genannt wird.
Wie benutzen wir Hashing?
Wenn der Benutzer signet, nehmen wir das Passwort, das sie bieten, generieren ein kleines Fingerprint oder Hashing und steuern es statt dem echten Passwort.
Ne.
In der Zukunft, wenn der Benutzer...
Chatge, das kann es ja schon aus einem ganz logischen Punkt nicht sein, weil von 2 hoch, wenn du, wenn du ein weiteres Passwort hast, 200, 2 hoch 256, würde dann bedeuten, also selbst wenn, wenn, gehen wir mal von außen.
Das wäre so, was es nicht ist, aber, ähm, eins davon ist ja schon mal weg, weil das kennst du ja.
Also, sein schon, das kann, kann da nicht stimmen.
...tries to log in, we take the password they typed in, we're in the same hashing process and see if the output hashes compare.
Ja.
If the hashes are the same...
So, so, so macht man das, wenn man, wenn man das gescheit speichern möchte, korrekt.
...that they typed in the correct password.
Keine Passwörter auf Serverseite.
Thanks to the power of hashing, we're able to verify someone's password without storing the actual password.
Bevor wir, bevor wir weitergucken, gucken, mal gucken, wer, wer von euch aufgepasst hat, nicht, nicht bei meinem jetzt, sondern, so, vielleicht hattet ihr das mal in der Schule oder sonst wo.
Was ist denn eines der Angriffsszenarien dafür?
Gehen wir mal von aus, wir haben jetzt hier unser Passwort, 123456, MD5SUM.
Ja, richtig, der Chat, der Chat weiß schon Bescheid.
Also, ich glaube, hier ist es relativ offensichtlich, was ein, was ein Schwachpunkt davon ist.
Und zwar, wenn ihr das hier findet, mal angenommen, ihr bekommt einen Datenbankdump irgendwoher und ihr findet diesen Hash in der Datenbank, dann könnt ihr relativ sicher sein, dass im Vorfeld schon jemand mal so übliche Passwörter durchprobiert hat, was die für Hashes ergeben und die abgespeichert hat.
Das heißt, ihr könnt dann einfach eine, ja, Reverse Lookup im Endeffekt machen, ihr habt dann ein Dictionary, wo drinne steht, dieser Input Hash ist dieses Passwort oder...
Du kannst halt nachgucken und bei so einfachen Sachen kannst du davon ausgehen, dass für alle gängigen Hashing-Algorithmen schon Tabellen existieren, wo du nachgucken kannst, welcher Hash rauskommt.
Das heißt, man sieht auch daran, dass es nicht unwichtig ist, ein ordentliches Passwort zu wählen.
Das ersetzt das nicht.
Also, wenn man im Vorfeld das schon, schon einen riesen, riesen Dictionary hat aus vorher, vorbereitenden Hashes.
Dann ist das ein Problem.
Und das ist übrigens auch bei, ihr seht ja, das ist auch bei SHA-256 das Problem.
Also rein, dass die einen sichereren Hashing-Algorithmus verwenden, macht euer unsicheres Passwort nicht sicherer.
Weil da könnt ihr Gift drauf nehmen, dass solche Tabellen für das ganze Reverse, ja, zu Lookupen, dass das auch für alle gängigen Hashing-Algorithmen existiert.
Werden die Usernamen dann auch gehashed?
Pfff, das ist sicherlich...
Implementierungsfrage, ähm, ein Salt mit zu hashen ist deutlich, deutlich sinniger.
Was Salt denn dann bringt?
Na, dass du nicht vorberechnen kannst.
Das ist das, was Salt bringt.
Da sag ich aber gleich was dazu, wenn der im Video dazu kommt.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat's grad mein...
Hä?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat's grad mein Browser zerlegt und er kam sogar genau wieder an der Stelle, wo ich aufgehört hab.
Alles klar.
Wir können jemanden Passwort überprüfen, ohne den echten Passwort zu steuern.
Hashing might sound a little magical at the moment.
How does hashing prevent someone from recovering their original password from the output hash?
And how does it prevent two strings from hashing to the same thing and allowing someone to log in with the wrong password?
Gar nicht.
Two strings, same hash, kann immer passieren.
Egal bei welchem Hashing-Algorithmus, das war sehr unwahrscheinlich, aber kann passieren.
Und turning the hash back into the password, das funktioniert nicht.
Okay, das muss...
Also ich hab ja gesagt, du kannst relativ easy von einem...
Hash auf ein Passwort schließen, wenn du es vorausberechnest.
Aber, nach dem Hashing, also rein streng genommen, weißt du nie, ob das hier wirklich das Passwort war, was hinter diesem Hash stand.
Nachdem es ja quasi unendlich viele Möglichkeiten gibt, dass der gleiche Hash rauskommt, weißt du logischerweise, wenn du den Hash kennst, dass das wirklich der Input war, der zu diesem Hash geführt hat.
Okay.
Es gibt keine Entschlüsselungsmöglichkeiten für Hashes.
Also du kannst nie einen Hash, ja, reverten, decrypten oder so.
Manche sagen ja, Hash entschlüsseln.
Das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Hash ist quasi verlustbehaftet, wie man hier sieht.
Ja, ich kann beliebig lang Input reinstecken.
Und am Ende kommt ein Output raus, der kürzer ist.
Und, also das geht nicht wirklich.
Ja, du kannst das nicht in das Passwort zurückturnen und dir sicher sein, dass das...
Das Passwort war, was auch wirklich benutzt wurde.
Musst du aber auch nicht.
Es reicht, wenn du eins rausbekommst.
Kein Hashing-Algorithmus ist kollisionsfrei.
Das Passwort ist das Original.
Der Prozess des Hashings betrifft eine Menge aggressiver Mischung der Daten in den originalen Input, um den Output zu produzieren.
Es ist wie drei Farben von verschiedenen Farben zu nehmen und sie zusammen zu mischen, was wahrscheinlich einen seltsamen Farben von Braun auswirkt.
Mit nur dem Braun, bist du wahrscheinlich nicht möglich, die originalen drei Farben zu mischen, die sie gemacht haben.
In der gleichen Weise kannst du nicht herausfinden, welches Passwort aus dem Hashings-Algorithmus das Original ist.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel. Das ist echt ein gutes Beispiel.
Weil die Bits in den Daten alle vollständig vermischt und gescrambelt wurden.
Diese Fähigkeit ist bekannt als eine Ein-Weg-Funktion, wie eine Ein-Weg-Straße.
Sobald du hashen kannst, kannst du nicht un-hashen.
Für das zweite, was ist, wie Hashing es schwierig macht, zwei Stringen zu hashen, die dem gleichen Wert genannt werden, als eine Hasch-Kollision.
Die Antwort ist ähnlich zu dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Die Hasch-Funktion mischt die Daten in so einem Weg, dass sogar kleine Wechsel in den Input,
resultieren in totalen...
Ich habe ja gerade gezeigt, dass das so ist.
... als Ergebnis, für gute Hasch-Funktionen, ist es kein öffentlich bekanntes Weg, zwei Stringen zu generieren, die Hasch-Kollisionen sammeln,
ohne nur viele, viele, viele Stringen zu probieren.
Keine Glückwünsche an diesen zehn.
Diese Fähigkeit heißt Kollision-Restriktion.
Die richtige Hasch-Funktion zu wählen, ist wichtig.
Wir haben gedacht, dass ältere Hasch-Funktionen, die ihr vielleicht gehört habt,
wie MD5 und SHA1, Kollision-Restriktion hatten,
aber die Kryptographik-Progress wächst auf und sie sind unbewusst verbessert.
Zum Beispiel, vor einer Dekade,
haben Forscher eine Methode veröffentlicht,
um eine Kollision zu generieren,
zwei Stringen, die den gleichen MD5-Hasch haben,
die ihr in etwa einem Sekunden auf eurem Laptop fahren könnt.
Also, wir haben uns auf eine stärkere Hasch-Funktion gelegt,
wie SHA2, die ich in diesem Video benutzt habe.
Wobei, habt ihr mitgekriegt, was er sagt?
Also, wir haben uns auf einen MD5-Hasch gelegt,
den ihr in etwa einem Sekunden auf eurem Laptop fahren könnt.
Also, wir haben uns auf eine stärkere Hasch-Funktion gelegt,
Ah, shit, Moment.
... Kryptographik-Progress wächst auf und sie sind unbewusst verbessert.
Zum Beispiel, vor einer Dekade,
haben Forscher eine Methode veröffentlicht,
um eine Kollision zu generieren,
zwei Stringen, die den gleichen MD5-Hasch haben,
die ihr in etwa einem Sekunden auf eurem Laptop fahren könnt.
Also, wir haben uns auf eine stärkere Hasch-Funktion gelegt,
Genau, also, man findet zwei Strings,
die den gleichen Hash ergeben.
Das ist aber was anderes,
wie eine Kollision finden,
zu einem String, den du vorgibst.
Ist logisch, ne?
Wenn du sagst, finde mal zwei Strings,
die den gleichen Hash-Wert erzeugen,
ist das, sagen wir mal so,
deutlich einfacher,
als eine Hash-Kollision zu finden,
zu einem Wert, den du vorgibst.
Das ist ähnlich wie,
hab ich ja gerade schon gesagt,
das ist ähnlich wie, wenn du eine Klasse hast,
mit, ähm,
ich glaub bei,
ab 28 Schülern ist es, glaube ich, so.
Also, wenn du eine Klasse hast,
mit
28 Schülern,
und du suchst jemand in der Klasse,
der am gleichen Tag Geburtstag hat,
wie du. Die Chance ist relativ gering.
Suchst du allerdings
zwei Leute,
die,
also, jetzt nicht, die an deinem Tag Geburtstag haben,
sondern suchst du in der Klasse
einfach nur zwei Leute,
die am gleichen Tag Geburtstag haben,
ist die Chance viel, viel höher,
und die Chance ist deutlich höher,
als man denkt.
Was denkt ihr denn, wenn ihr eine Klasse habt,
mit 28 Leuten drin,
wie hoch die Chance ist,
dass zwei Leute am gleichen Geburtstag haben?
60? 30?
Äh, gucken, ob es da,
ob es einen Online-Rechner für gibt.
Ich bin zu pepega, dass aus der,
aus dem, hier jetzt,
okay,
ja, hier haben wir es, okay.
Ja, das ist natürlich,
genau, wieviel hast du am gleichen Tag Geburtstag?
Also, wieviel Personen hast du?
So, zwei Tage am gleichen,
bei 25 Leuten,
ist es schon so,
dass du, dass die Chance,
dass zwei Leute am gleichen Tag Geburtstag haben,
aus, also aus einer Gruppe,
oder aus einer Menge, muss man sagen,
aus einer Gruppe von 25 Leuten,
dass zwei Leute am gleichen Tag Geburtstag haben,
ist,
650 Prozent.
Und mein Beispiel mit 28,
wären es sogar 65 Prozent.
Also, in Schulklassen,
in Schulklassen,
in heutigen Schulklassen,
die teilweise irgendwie 35 Leute haben,
oder so,
ist es sogar eher unwahrscheinlich,
dass du keinen Tag findest,
wo nicht mal zwei Leute am gleichen Tag Geburtstag haben.
Warum?
Ja, da musst du dir mal,
da musst du dir eine Webseite mal dazu durchlesen,
oder den Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu.
So, we've moved on to stronger hash functions,
like SHA-2, which is the one I've been using in this video.
With our new hashing technique under our belt,
let's hash all the passwords in our database
instead of encrypting them,
to arrive at C to your password storage.
Now, we don't have a key that effortlessly unlocks
the password table like before,
which is definitely an improvement.
However, we need to talk about dictionary attacks.
As it turns out,
many people use extremely weak passwords
like password or 123456.
If a hacker has access to your database,
they can just run your hash function
on password or 123456
to get the hash, and then find all the hashes
that match in your database.
Voila, they've broken those people's passwords.
This is called a dictionary attack,
because you can run through the dictionary
by hashing words as you go
and seeing if any of them match the hash.
Remember that it's not possible
to directly turn a hash back into a password, in general.
However, because the hacker knows
the hash came from a password,
they can use their knowledge of human nature
to narrow down the possible guesses,
which makes guessing feasible.
Furthermore, they can use lists of the most common passwords
to pre-generate a huge database of hashes.
So all they need to do
is to compare their huge database
to your database to find matches.
These databases are known as rainbow tables.
How can we defend against this?
Let's go to B tier for a technique
that protects against rainbow tables,
but not against dictionary attacks.
It's a technique called salting.
When the user signs up,
rather than directly hashing each password,
Salting ist im Prinzip ganz einfach erklärt.
Ihr nehmt nicht einfach nur
euer Passwort,
das ihr hashen wollt,
sondern
ihr packt noch
einen Hashtag, einen Random Salt
mit rein.
So, das hier ist jetzt mein Random Salt.
Achso, da war ein Sonderzeichen
für die Shell drin.
So, das ist jetzt
mein Random Salt.
Da kommt ein anderer Hash bei raus.
Hat den riesen Vorteil,
dass du
jetzt keine vorberechnenden Tabellen
mehr benutzen kannst.
Du kannst nach wie vor
das mit einer Grafikkarte durchprobieren,
aber du kannst keine vorberechnenden Tabellen
benutzen, weil der Random Hash
im Vorfeld ja nicht bekannt ist.
Die Hashes geben ja auch keine
Informationen über den Input.
Die Hashes geben keine Informationen
über den Input. Du kannst dir nicht sicher sein,
dass das, was du in so einer
Tabelle guckst, wirklich das Passwort
war, was eingegeben wurde,
um diesen Hash zu erzeugen.
Das weißt du nicht. Es gibt ja theoretisch
unendlich viele Inputs.
Es reicht dir aber,
wenn du es
einfach findest, wenn der gleiche Hash rauskommt.
Kann man den Salt-Wert nicht
herausfinden mit Datenbankzugriff?
Doch, der Salt-Wert
ist bekannt
oftmals.
Der Salt-Wert ist nichts Geheimes.
Man muss ihn jetzt vielleicht nicht öffentlich auf die Website
stellen, aber der Salt-Wert ist prinzipiell nichts Geheimes.
Der Salt-Wert,
du brauchst den Salt-Wert sogar.
Du musst
den Salt-Wert sogar im Plaintext
übertragen. Nein, im Plaintext nicht, aber
du musst den Salt-Wert sogar übertragen können
im Nachhinein. Der Salt-Wert
ist nur dafür da, dass niemand
hingehen kann
und petabyteweise
Tabellen erstellen kann im Vorfeld.
Das ist der einzige Sinn
von einem Salt. Der Salt ist nicht dafür geheim
zu sein. Der Salt kann bekannt sein.
Der Salt ist nur dafür da, dass keiner
im Vorfeld vorberechnete
Tabellen anfertigen kann.
Weil der Salt ja random
ist und für jeden Fall individuell.
Das heißt, du kannst nicht einfach eine Tabelle nehmen
für
du kannst jetzt nicht einfach petabyte
Tabelle nehmen für
einen Salt und die mit dem anderen
verwenden. Das geht nicht.
Der Salt ist nur dafür da, um quasi den Rechenaufwand
zu erhöhen und den Speicheraufwand
und alles zu erhöhen. Richtig.
Genau. Der Salt ist
nichts geheimes. Der Salt steht
übrigens auch, wenn ihr mal
in
etc shadow
guckt,
steht da hier
example etc shadow
das ist die Datei, wo unter
Linux die Passwörter drinstehen.
Guck hier. So. Da seht ihr
das. Ich glaube, das hier ist der Salt.
Ich glaube, das ist der Salt.
Also ihr könnt hier reingucken.
Also das hier ist das Interessante.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie hier was
ich glaube, das ist der Hashing Algorithmus
und das ist der Hash
und das ist glaube ich der Salt.
Ja, richtig.
Habe ich doch recht. Also
so ist das Format von
der Linux Passwort Datei. Also
das erste ist der Hashing Algorithmus, der
verwendet wird.
Das zweite ist
der Salt, würde ich mal
sagen, auch wenn es jetzt hier nicht so wirklich
drin ist.
Ah ja, doch hier. ID Salt
Hasht. Genau. Also eins
ist der Hashing Algorithmus, der verwendet wird.
Der muss bekannt sein. Der darf
auch nicht geheim sein, weil der Client
muss ja das gleiche nochmal machen. Der muss bekannt
sein. Der Salt kann
auch Plain Text bekannt sein
und dann hast du den Hash dazu. Das ist hier
quasi das gehashte Passwort.
Und dadurch, dass quasi dieser Salt
random generiert hier individuell
für jeden User ist, kannst du nicht
einfach eine
riesen Cluster nehmen mit Grafikkarten
und drei Jahre lang
Tabellen generieren lassen, weil dir
die Tabelle nichts bringt, weil
der Salt für jeden Input anders ist.
Also Salt und
Algorithmus können ruhig bekannt sein.
Das macht nix.
Salt next to the hashed password.
When the user logs in, we can prepend
the remembered Salt to the password they entered
and hash to see if it matches the stored password.
Das ist das, was ich euch auch gerade gezeigt habe auf der Kommandschein.
It's of course the same Salt at login that was generated
during signup. Und man sieht auch, dass der Salt
bekannt sein muss, weil
wenn ich im Backend Salt
plus Hash gespeichert habe, also ich habe in meinem
Backend in der Datenbank stehen,
User Max benutzt
Hash Algorithmus Chart 256
mit diesem Salt
und diesem Passwort Hash.
Wenn der Max sich jetzt einloggen will,
dann muss ich dem Browser
mitteilen, ey, verwende mal
Chart 256 beim
User Passwort
Login und
mit diesem Salt.
Dann tippe ich das Passwort ein, im Hintergrund nimmt man
den richtigen Hashing Algorithmus,
steckt den Salt rein, überträgt den
Hash und dann kann ich gucken, aha,
scheint wohl zu stimmen.
Also der Salt, der muss
sogar Plain Text sein.
Das machst du im Browser.
Du hast im Backend den Hash, den Salt
und den Algorithmus gespeichert und der
Browser, der ist die einzige
Stelle, die das Passwort im Plain Text jemals
sieht.
Du machst das, du machst das
kleinseitig.
Wie willst du es denn sonst machen?
Ich meine, wie willst du es denn
sonst machen?
Das würde nicht funktionieren.
Beim klassischen, wir machen
einen
Basic Auth
oder so, da ist es nicht so.
Bei Basic Auth wird das ganze
als Base 64
encoded im Klartext
übertragen.
Glücklicherweise über TLS, aber das
kannst du knicken. Also Basic Auth
ist nicht der
beste Beispiel.
Wenn du es richtig machen willst, würdest du das so machen.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die meisten
Authentifizierungslibraries das auch so machen.
Aber du kannst es ja, du musst es ja,
aus der Logik heraus
musst du es ja im Browser machen
oder im Client machen, weil dein Backend
kennt das Passwort ja gar nicht.
Dein Backend kann das gar nicht machen.
Dein Backend oder die Datenbank kennt ja wirklich nur
den Hash, den Algorithmus
und den Salt.
Das heißt, es muss ja an der
Stelle passieren, wo das Passwort
im Klartext bekannt ist. Und das ist beim User
im Client. Basic Auth ist nicht
unbedingt das beste Beispiel dafür, weil
da ist eh alles vorbei.
Da kannst du dich nur noch darauf verlassen, dass
das Ganze eben über TLS geht und deswegen
nichts passiert. Kann man
bestimmt auch machen. Aber es ist halt blöd,
wenn das Passwort in irgendeiner Art und Weise überhaupt
übertragen wird. Ich meine, das
kannst du auch machen. Du kannst das Passwort
übertragen, im Backend hashen und gucken, ob der
gespeicherte Hash rauskommt. Das kannst du auch machen.
Also, ich habe sogar ein Beispiel
für, wie das
unterschiedliche Sachen,
also wie Services
die das unterschiedlich gemacht haben.
Ich denke mal, viele werden es tatsächlich
so machen, zum Überprüfen. Ja, du schickst das Passwort
im Plaintext rüber über TLS
und dann wird das dort
gehasht und überprüft.
Im Falle von ICQ früher
war es umgedreht. Da wurde das auf dem
Client gemacht und
dementsprechend konntest du dich mit
dem
Hash als Passwort
quasi einloggen. Also, wenn du
quasi die Kommunikation
mitgeschnitten hattest damals mit ICQ,
und den Hash wusstest,
dann konntest du den Hash
übertragen an ICQ und das hat dich einloggen
lassen. Das hat damals funktioniert.
Am schönsten ist natürlich, wenn
das Passwort nie den Client verlassen muss.
Aber du hast schon recht, wahrscheinlich ist
das die verbreitetere
Variante.
Da habe ich
gerade nicht dran gedacht. Da hast du, denke
ich, recht, ja. Also bei ICQ
damals hatten sie es auf jeden Fall so gemacht,
du kannst dich mit dem Passwort Hash einloggen,
wenn du halt das mitgeschnitten hast und
dementsprechend geschickt hast.
Wenn die Webseite ohne JavaScript,
dann hast du eh gelitten.
Dann bleibt dir ja nur,
was macht ein Browser ohne JavaScript
standardmäßig? Was kannst du denn da machen?
Basic Auth und wie heißt das andere?
Digest
oder sowas? Gedöns?
Ich sag keine Ahnung.
Ich mein, heutzutage ist das glücklicherweise
halb so wild, weil das alles über
HTTPS, TLS geht.
WebAssembly.
Weiter.
Ja, das stimmt!
Das stimmts.
Du kannst da nix vorberechnendes benutzen
und brauchst halt im Zweifelsfall ewig.
Außer das Passwort ist kacke, ne?
...
das stimmt.
Du kannst halt nix
vorberechenes benutzen
und brauchst dann im Zweifelsfall ewig.
Außer das Passwort ist kacke, ne?
...
Spezialisiertes Hardware, wie GPUs, hat es möglich gemacht, dass Menschen Billionen von Hashen pro Sekunde kompensieren,
was sich in Billionen von Gästen pro Sekunde darstellt.
Wie auf der Erde stoppen wir das?
Schauen wir mal, was A-Tier sagen muss.
Ein A-Tier nutzt eine spezialisierte Passwort-Hashing-Funktion, die unabhängig langsam ist.
Die vorherigen Hashing-Funktionen, die wir besprochen haben, sind gestaltet, um schnell zu sein,
weil sie für andere Applikationen außer Passwörter genutzt werden.
Passwort-Hashing-Funktionen wie bcrypt, scrypt und argon2 kommen mit kostenlosem Salten
und mehr wichtig sind, um wirklich, wirklich, wirklich langsam zu sein,
um viel Kraft zu verbrauchen und viel Erinnerung zu nehmen.
Das klingt seltsam, aber das ist tatsächlich aufgrund der...
... um gegen die überwältigende Kraft von Hardware zu verteidigen.
Die Billionen von Hashings pro Sekunde, die wir vor kurzem gesehen haben,
können nur zu Tausenden pro Sekunde langsam werden, wenn nicht sogar langsamer,
weil man tatsächlich den Niveau der Langsamkeit wählen kann, den man will.
Dies ist der Work-Faktor.
Nein, Darkzone, das ist doch gerade, das ist der Trick da dran.
Das ist, im Prinzip kann man das übertragen auf nahezu, sagen wir mal, alle guten kryptografischen Sachen.
Du musst wissen, du darfst wissen, wie es funktioniert,
aber trotzdem, dass du weißt, wie es funktioniert,
darfst du trotzdem nicht an den Plaintext kommen.
Nur durch das Wissen, wie der Algorithmus funktioniert.
Du kannst wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Das ist im Prinzip ähnlich, wir nehmen was ganz, was ganz Simples.
Nehmen eine Modulo-Operation.
Hau irgendwas Mod 5 durch.
Du kannst aus dem, was da rauskommt,
keine wirklichen Rückschlüsse draus ziehen, welche Zahl,
die das Ergebnis geliefert hat.
Und du weißt, was passiert.
Es wird Mod 5 gemacht.
Aber nur weil du weißt, dass Mod 5 gemacht wird, wie Mod 5 funktioniert,
heißt das noch lange nicht, dass du rausbekommst, was als Input reingeschoben wurde.
Also du musst wissen können, wie es funktioniert,
aber du darfst trotzdem nicht damit weiterkommen.
Oh, jetzt kommen die, jetzt ist High-IQ-Chat am Start hier.
... von Wissen pro Sekunde.
Das ist immer noch genug, um die meisten üblichen Passwörter durchzuführen,
aber es ist nicht genug, um hübschere oder abschärfere Passwörter zu brechen.
Mit einem hohen Work-Faktor können Hacker einige der Passwörter in deinem System brechen,
aber nicht alle.
Nach allem ist das Ziel der Sicherheit, nicht immun zu Attacken zu sein, was unmöglich ist,
sondern genug zu verhindern, dass sie ihre Aufmerksamkeit an andere Orte wechseln.
Als konkretes Beispiel schauen wir uns Bcrypt an.
Das Output von Bcrypt sieht so aus.
Es hat ein Präfix, das das Output als ein Bcrypt-Ding identifiziert,
einen Work-Faktor, einen 22-Charakter-Salt und einen 31-Charakter-Hash.
Das Wichtigste daran ist,
dass der Work-Faktor exponentiell ist.
Wenn du den Work-Faktor mit einem erhöhen,
wird die Funktion zweimal so langsam.
Hier ist ein Graph von Bcrypt-Hashtime mit Work-Faktor auf meinem Laptop.
Der exponentielle erhöhen ist ziemlich klar.
Die meisten Leute empfehlen...
Vergesst mal den Part, den ich euch erzählt habe,
über man sollte immer das Client-seitig machen,
weil, wenn ich mir so recht Gedanken drüber mache,
ist es eigentlich bescheuert, alles rein Client-seitig zu machen,
auch wenn das ICQ früher so gemacht hat,
aber ICQ ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so das Aushängeschild für Sachen,
wie man machen sollte,
weil, wenn du rein Client-seitig hasht und das dann überträgst, um zu gucken,
ob du authentifiziert werden kannst,
dann bedeutet das ja im Endeffekt,
dass du eigentlich das Passwort im Plaintext speicherst,
weil der Hash ja dann quasi das Passwort ist.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich sinnlos.
Also, da hat er auf jeden Fall recht.
Genau, das habe ich mir auch gerade überlegt.
Also, ne, das ist dann...
Vergesst mal den Part, den ich erzählt habe,
immer rein Client-seitig machen,
ergibt auch eigentlich keinen Sinn.
Ja.
Oh, weiter.
Naja, 2 Milliseconds ist gar nicht mal pro Hash,
klingt jetzt wenig,
aber ganz im Ernst, wenn du Milliarden durchprobieren musst,
dann werden auch 2 Milliseconds relativ viel.
Ja, gut.
Ja, gut!
Haha.
Ja, gut.
S-Sign in with Aliexpress? Alibaba?
Haha.
Nacht, wissend, dass dein System überhaupt keine Passwörter hat. Das ist alles für heute.
Lass uns aufmerksam machen. Zuerst haben wir die Passwörter in Plaintext angeschaut, was bedeutet, dass jeder einfach akzeptieren kann.
Wie hieß er denn?
Ähm, er hat es gepackt.
Nice.
Und was war es? Ich habe das gar nicht gelesen.
So weit geht mein Chat nicht zurück.
Der Reset hat es gefixt. Okay, dann.
Siehste.
HiFat Remote Chat Support hat es geregelt.
Abrechnung kommt.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns, Leute.
Ich gehe jetzt futtern.
Bis dann. See you.